published which means that this will be
even higher in the next few weeks i'm
wondering at what point of the crisis in
the health service in northern ireland
will the health minister here be able to
step in with emergency provision
emergency organization i wonder if the
business leader can raise this urgently
with the health secretary
well that is is very uh
hard to hear
i think one of the strengths of our
national health service across the
united kingdom is that it is devolved
and it is run in slightly different ways
and
the chief medical officers i know work
together very closely to share good
practice to learn from each other and
strengthen the system as a whole
i will certainly
raise his concerns with the new
secretary of state but he will know that
we are doing everything we can to
restore
a government in uh in northern ireland
so these issues can be gripped and dealt
with
robin
walker welcome my right honourable
friend to her base i think she'll be a
fantastic champion for this house and i
welcome the speed with which for
government is bringing forward measures
uh to address the energy crisis
alongside that in my inbox the number
one issue from constituents is the the
fate of future of the worcester warriors
rugby club professional rugby has been
played at six ways for all of my adult
lifetime uh but this is now under threat
due to the entire financial situation at
the club five worcestershire mps have
written together to both the incoming
and the outgoing secretary of state uh
for dcms and i'm delighted uh thank you
mr speaker that the speaker has allowed
for an adjournment debate on this issue
on september the 19th but i fear that
may be too late we need urgent action by
the dcms uh the premier uh premier rugby
and the rf
you to save the future of this club are
there any opportunities uh for me to
raise this issue even sooner than next
monday the monday afternoon well i thank
my uh honorable friend for the work that
he and his local colleagues are doing to
secure this club's future uh he has uh
done exactly as uh you would expect him
uh to to do so in uh securing that
debate but uh time is of the essence i
will happily raise this issue on his
behalf
and ensure that the new secretary of
state realizes it is a priority we have
uh previously assisted uh clubs uh in
even if it is just buying them
a bit of time uh and i know uh that the
new secretary of state would be keen to
do all they can to assist
thank you
speaker the governor have taken 4.4
billion pounds from the mine workers
pension scheme today the cross-party bay
select committee report concluded that
the government should not be in the
business of profiting from miners
pensions myself and 50 colleagues wrote
to the two leadership candidates last
month about this we are yet to receive a
reply so can i ask can we have an urgent
statement from this new government on
this scandal yeah
[Applause]
well i thank the honorable lady for uh
for raising this matter she can clearly
raise it as a as a question uh to that
department or seek to secure a debate uh
but i would be happy to notify the
relevant department that is a concern to
her and ask them to get in touch
bob blackman thank you deputy speaker
before the recess i raised the plight of
uh jabba kyle a young afghan boy who
became separated from his family when
they fled
afghanistan
very sadly he ended up in paris while
the rest of the family ended up here
over the last 12 months his solicitor
the family and my office have been
trying to get him reunited with his
family the good news is
yesterday he arrived
at king's cross and he was united with
his twin brother however this highlights
the problems there are of both afghan
refugees and other refugees who are
separated from their families across the
world
equally 11 000 afghan refugees are still
in hotels in this country so can we have
a debate in government time on the
plights of refugees and how we can
ensure we short circuit this and get
people into decent homes that they can
make their own here
well i know my uh honorable friend is an
assiduous campaigner on these issues and
continues to uh raise
his concerns but also concerns shared by
many members of this house i know that
the new home secretary will be looking
at these issues and also asking other
government departments to uh
to to grip these issues i will be happy
to raise this issue on his behalf
and will certainly uh uh encourage uh
the home office uh to as i mentioned
before uh to be as helpful to members of
this house in resolving these cases
richard gibson
thank you madam deputy speaker
marie curie's dying in poverty campaign
is calling for for urgent action from
the uk to safeguard terminally ill
people and their families against
poverty at the end of their lives
will the leader of the house make a
statement setting out her support for
this campaign and will she use her good
offices to urge her cabinet colleagues
to do likewise and put an end to the
shameful indictment of our society where
people die in poverty
well i thank the honourable lady for
raising this issue she will know that
there there is uh something in today's
business where members will be able to
uh make some progress on this issue uh
but i know it's connected to a whole
raft of things and i'll be happy uh to
to point the new uh secretary of state
towards the honourable ladies concerns
anthony magnol
deputy speaker there aren't really
enough hours in the day to speak about
fishing and farming but with that in
mind could the uh leader of the house
please give us more time in defra
questions to be able to ask questions on
rural affairs
thank you uh um thanks to the honourable
gentleman from
uh reminding uh all of us in this house
of the the vital uh importance of uh
farming fishing and uh and rural affairs
i shall certainly talk to the new
secretary of state about his concerns
mary sherman
speaker can i warmly welcome the new
leader of the house and look forward to
our thursdays together uh but can i uh
remind her that uh the lovely cheryl
gillum some years ago managed to get the
autism act through his place
will we could we have an early debate on
the fact that autism is a very important
issue for so many families in this
country and up and down the country many
local authorities are ignoring the act
failing to put it into operation and
leaving families in a dreadful state of
despair could we have an early debate on
it
well i thank uh the honourable gentleman
for for reminding us of the service that
uh that cheryl gillum formed one of the
many services she performed for this
house in bringing uh that act in
supported by many members of this house
it has been in operation for some time
and i think we should look at uh how it
is performing uh i would encourage him
to apply uh for debates in the usual
manner but i will be happy to to raise
it with the the several relevant
departments uh so that they can consider
his request it's elaine saxby thank you
madam deputy speaker and can i
congratulate and welcome my right
honourable friend to her new position
following the shocking fire ten days ago
at beautiful baggy point in my stunning
north devon constituency caused by a
disposable barbecue blowing up from the
beach onto the tinder dry gorse please
can we have an urgent debate in
government time to consider banning
these dangerous and unnecessary items
from our open spaces
well this is a this was a particularly
shocking incident um natural fires are a
tragedy in themselves but when it is
preventable and it's been caused by uh
by such an event it is uh it is very
depressing uh the government is ensuring
that disposable barbecues are safe and
include clear instructions uh to use but
clearly there is a lack of awareness
about the potential of what might happen
and i thank the honourable lady for
raising awareness of that today and i
know she will continue to do so and i'll
be happy to raise the issue with the
department
alan brown
madame deputy speaker
keep homes about a new house in the
state in my constituency often people
dream homes however many constituents
had issues with snagging the the
struggle to resolve
um there was actually a land grab by
keep mope where some gardens are smaller
and sworn in the title deeds of the
houses purchased the general upkeep of
the the state is very poor strain with
weeds and general maintenance is working
and adjacent land still owned by keep
more is effective on wasteland i keep
homes keep fobbing off my office
promising to get back to never do well
of course i'm making more money about
building houses elsewhere so can i get a
statement from the leader of the house
and how we can hold these so-called
regular companies to account and make
them fulfill on their promises
well he has certainly raised awareness
of the conduct of that company today on
the floor of this house and done his
constituents a service in the process
he will know that he will be able to
secure perhaps an adjournment debate
so to further discuss
what this business is and isn't doing
jonathan cullers thank you very much
ma'am dr speaker earlier this week
stoke-on-trent city football club are
proud to host our heroines the lionesses
as they storm to a 10-year victory over
luxembourg in their world cup qualify in
front of a 24 000 strong crowd it was a
tremendous boost to the city of stoke on
trent and a great showcase for women's
football so will my right honourable
friend join me in congratulating the
lionesses in their victory and can we
secure parliamentary time to debate how
we can improve access and opportunity
for girls and women across our country
to get into football yeah yeah well i
thank my honourable friend for again
reminding us of the lionesses tremendous
uh and continuing uh track record in uh
bringing glory to our our nation i'm
happy to say that it was announced this
week that former england and great
britain footballer karen carney mbe is
to chair an in-depth review into the
future of domestic women's football
which will look at how we deliver both
growth to elite and grassroot level
football and next week there is a
westminster hall debate on the 2022 uefa
european women's championship and
participation of girls and young women
in sport and i would encourage all
members to contribute to that debate
uh florence sashalomi thank you madam
deputy speaker on the 25th of august my
constituent victoria bauman and her
husband were arrested in neymar for
alleged visa offences as they returned
from the city of shan state
miss bauman served as the uk's
ambassador to neymar and the neymar
center for responsible business said
that she has dedicated many years in
strengthening social and economic
development in neymar she is an
upstanding citizen who served our
country with distinction and these
charges appear politically motivated so
can the leader of the house please
discuss this with the foreign secretary
and look at how we can urgently help my
constituent and her husband
well i thank the honourable lady for
raising this issue i shall pass her
concerns on to
the foreign office and i would encourage
her to make contact with the new foreign
secretary to discuss these matters
directly sean bailey thank you speaker
uh speaker uh this it was great to see
my writing friend in her place today if
she takes her position and i warmly
congratulate her uh samuel metropolitan
borough council were awarded 20 million
pounds by this government for a family
hub and we all know that this how you
start in life unfortunately still
dictates sometimes when we go we need to
change that and the family hub can do
that now my dr speaker i'm campaigning
along with local campaigners to be sure
there is a family hood located in
harvard's hawthorne in my constituency
in west bromwich now the harvest
hawthorne primary school have the site
they have the connections and they have
the networks by which to build this we
just need to get samwell council on
board so we'll more out of a friend give
us a debate government time perhaps make
representations in government to support
the campaign to get a family hub at
harvard's hawthorne primary school in
west bromwich
well my honourable friend is absolutely
right and indeed a former leader of the
house who is uh here in the chamber
today has done a huge amount of work uh
on uh early years and encouraging
these family hubs he is right to
campaign so hard for one in his uh
constituency and i'd be very happy to
help him achieve that objective what i
would say is this particular council is
featuring greatly uh in uh in business
questions today and uh i think maybe uh
honorable members should club together
in their application for a debate uh
whether it is on denying people
who have special education needs
transport or indeed uh being a block on
family hubs being set up in
constituencies
carol monaghan
this year
sorry this week i received a rather
predictable response from the home
office
thank you for your further inquiry on
behalf of x about his application for
why
x's application is under consideration
and we will contact him as soon as the
decision is reached it was predictable
because it's the same response i get
every time i contact the home office now
this week um the home office sent us a
letter that says now they will be
contacting our offices to update them by
telephone not by email now call me a
cynic but we lose a paper trail when
it's an email update and so can we have
a government statement on what has been
done about these
unacceptable delays in home office a
correspondence and applications from our
constituents
order if we are to get everybody in we
do need um quite short questions leader
of the house i
i'm aware of the correspondence that the
home office uh have sent out i very much
doubt whether whether that
correspondence had any ministerial
oversight on it uh i have raised it with
the home office and said that our view
is that this is not an acceptable
service for members uh and i think they
do not understand that uh having a
having a letter with a substantive
answer is is very helpful to members in
terms of getting information to their
constituents i have raised it both with
the home office and with the cabinet
office and will do all i can to ensure
that members of this house get the
service they and their constituents need
scott benton mr speaker welcome my right
honourable friend to a new position on
the front bench 28 000 migrants have now
crossed the channel this year and i'm
afraid that our inability to control our
borders is becoming increasingly
difficult to defend to my constituents
can we expect a statement from a new
home secretary on this issue and the
further measures the government will be
taking to address this yeah
i think you can expect to hear from the
new home secretary soon on these matters
it is a key priority for her and in
addition to statements you will also see
action
dan jarvis thank you madam deputy
speaker can i warmly welcome the leader
of the house to her important new role
and i wish her well with it i suspect
the right honourable lady has been
studiously looking at the commitments
the prime minister has made over the
course of the summer so she will know
that in a speech in leeds on the 28th of
july the prime minister committed to
build the northern powerhouse rail link
to join up communities and unlock
potential rights across the north that
is hugely significant for the north of
england and i know the metro mayors in
west yorkshire tracy brabian and south
yorkshire oliver bray oliver coppad are
very keen to talk to the government so
can the leader speak to the new
transport secretary so we can get early
sight of the government's intentions
with this regard
leader of the house uh like him very
pleased to hear that commitment from our
new prime minister the timing but also
the sequencing of these uh various
schemes will be of huge interest to many
members of this house and i think it is
a prime topic uh for a debate uh and i
would encourage him to apply for for one
daisy
cooper on the 13th of may almost four
months ago i wrote to the secretary of
state for health and social care about a
constituent who suffered a serious
sexual assault at the hands of a medical
professional my research has shown that
there is no support available for these
kinds of people no progress on
implementing recommendations of three
inquiries and no systematic collection
of data i chased up with the secretary
of state on the 21st of july the 10th of
august and yesterday on the 7th of
september could the leader of the house
please confirm she will now write to the
new secretary of state and ensure that
my constituent having been incredibly
courageous will get a response to my
letter of almost four months ago
well i'm very sorry to hear about the
the case of the honourable ladies
constituent i shall certainly raise this
matter and draw it to the attention of
the new secretary of state
ruth jones thank you madam deputy
speaker and i wish the leader well in
her new role obviously an apprenticeship
for the top job
on the steps of downing street this week
the new prime minister failed to mention
wales once and that's not gone unnoticed
in wales and in my constituency of
newport west so can we have a debate in
government time on the lessons the party
opposite can learn from the long-term
and successful welsh labour government
because there are plenty of people
um well i thank the uh honourable lady
for her question i would i would
slightly take issue with uh the success
rate of the welsh government on a on a
number of fronts but in the spirit of
cooperation i shall encourage her to uh
apply for an abate so that we can have
that discussion on the floor of the
house
chris
law thank you madam deputy speaker i've
requested meetings in the home office to
discuss the exceptional case of a young
woman from afghanistan who's been
offered a place to study nursing
university of dundee this is an
absolutely urgent case since this was
resolved prior to start of a course this
month i also understand it's on the
ministerial desk awaiting approval so
can the leader of the house advise
members and what they can do to raise
urgent cases with ministers and will she
help facilitate a meeting for me with
colleagues in the home office
i should be happy to facilitate meetings
if the honorable gentleman is having
difficulty securing them and as i have
said uh today and yesterday i'm sure the
home office will want to give clarity to
precisely the uh support it will give
members to resolve such issues
rachel hopkins thank you mr speaker and
if i may given the new leader of the
house's experience of the fantastic
inspire sports centre in luton south
will she join me in congratulating amy
rollinson from luton diving club on her
bronze medal in the commonwealth games
but if i can quickly ask given the
devastating floods in pakistan a third
of the country is underwater 35 million
people are affected over 1200 dead
please can we have an urgent debate
about uka to pakistan
well i will happily join her in giving
her the congratulations uh that she
outlined for the uh the achievements in
diving uh in her uh constituency uh she
will know that we have given uh many
millions in uh aid money uh to help with
the situation in in pakistan and our
high commission there is doing all it
can to uh assist uh the the government
in the very difficult circumstances that
they are facing and i would encourage
her and others to apply for debates in
the usual manner bris stevens
our remedial order can only take effect
after 60 sitting days after it's been
laid down we've been waiting far too
long for the second remedial order to be
laid down for even support payments for
cohabiting couples can the leader tell
us when the government plan to lay down
that second remedial order yeah
well i'm very aware that because these
are sitting days this isn't it's a
longer period of time and there are many
issues that honourable members have
raised today that do need to be dealt
with swiftly
i am having discussions with my team and
the deputy leader of the house about how
we can ensure the measures that are
urgently needed are brought forward in
the swiftest possible time
very garden
delays to cancer treatment can be a
matter of life and death
yet the government
is still not meeting seven of the nine
urgent referral cancer targets could we
have a debate in government time about
how we can improve the situation for
those weighting
their cancer treatment
i thank the honourable gentleman for for
raising this issue
much of the waiting list uh pressures
that the nhs is under is because of
diagnostics and i know it would be a key
focus for the new secretary of state i
would encourage him to apply for an
abate a debate in the usual manner
speaker let me congratulate the leader
of the house in their appointment my
constituency celebrates two very
important anniversaries this year first
of all the 150th anniversary of the
foundation of the sons of the rock
dumbarton fc which two members of my
family have actually played for and also
of course the 800th anniversary of the
royal buddha of dumbarton founded by our
late king alexander ii by the grace of
god king of scots so i wonder will the
leader of the house not only
congratulate dumbarton fc but the people
of dumbarton and their ancient history
but also say it's about time we
recognize the value of sport and also
our great brothers across these islands
well i'm very happy to uh join the uh
honorable gentleman in uh
congratulations of both those
achievements and i wish uh i wish them
well uh in future years davis jones
speaker shamefully unnecessary delays to
the online safety bill has allowed
dangerous misogyny and right-wing
extremism to perpetuate online for far
too long we know young boys are
especially susceptible to this and more
and more turning to the dark web in an
attempt to find a place of belonging and
acceptance will the leader of the house
therefore commit to a debate in
government time just look at how we can
tackle this way of radicalization before
it is too late
well i thank the honourable lady for
raising this and point her to the
remarks the prime minister made
yesterday
about our commitment to uh that bill uh
its progress is very important and we'll
obviously members will be able to
contribute to that but if she wishes to
have a further debate i would encourage
her to apply for one in the usual way
gareth thomas
the brenda mishra
thank you mr speaker i pay tribute to
all firefighters in stock court and
across the country you work in very
difficult
conditions to keep people safe
shockingly data from the fire brigades
union shows that between 2010 and 2021
we lost 631 full-time firefighter roles
in greater manchester this is
unacceptable and poses a real threat to
the public where fire and rescue
services may not be able to deal with
every incident and fight all fires as
the new prime minister starts a term
there's a real opportunity to properly
invest in the fire services again so
will the leader of the house allow a
debate in government time on funding for
the fire and rescue services in greater
manchester in light of the years of cuts
well i thank you honourable gentlemen
for raising this question uh these
matters are uh for local people to
decide but clearly the shape of the fire
service is changing they're taking on
additional roles as well as their
traditional ones and that will be a
concern for many members across this
house and i'd encourage him to apply for
a debate in the usual way
according to a uk finance report push
payment fraud rose by 39
last year that's no surprise to me
having spent the summer discussing this
with affected constituents
so i think that more teeth are needed we
need to find a way to make sure we have
proper redress for consumers and
businesses affected and a way of dealing
with banks who are hosting the accounts
which are benefiting from these high
value frauds so can we have a debate in
government time on what more can be done
here to make sure that we put an end to
this very damaging and increasing fraud
well the honourable lady raises an
important issue i know that this has
been a focus uh for the treasury uh in
recent months uh and certainly that if
she would apply for a debate i'm sure
many members would wish to contribute
thank you mr speaker this sunday
this sunday marks world suicide
prevention day and yesterday i along
with the right honourable member for
north durham met matthew from if you
care share
who is raising funds to support the work
of the charity running from durham to 10
downing street
can i ask for a debate in government
time so that we can discuss suicide and
self-harm prevention and the
government's revision of the
well i strategy the honourable lady for
raising that important issue and i wish
her constituent well uh on his mission
to to raise awareness and funds for this
important cause i will happily raise the
issue with the relevant secretary of
state and i'm sure if she were to secure
a debate and i would encourage her to
apply for one many members of this house
would wish to contribute gerald jones
thank you mr speaker over the summer by
many other members i'm sure my office
team have continued to experience
considerable delays in the contacting
the mp account management team at uk
visas and passport office twice in the
last few days staff has spent over two
hours on the phone getting to an advisor
and then the advisor are not able to
give information only read from a screen
and not give uh assistance on complex
cases so could i ask the leader of the
house please to arrange a debate in
government time to talk about what
action the government can take to ensure
members are provided with the support so
that we in turn can give that support to
our constituents
he will know that the home office has
done a huge amount to improve uh this
service uh taking on in in recent months
over a thousand new uh staff uh to be
able to uh process such applications but
he is right uh the there is no point in
having an mp's service and hotline if
answers are not at the end of it and i
shall certainly continue to ensure the
home office is able to deliver the
services that members of this house need
and would welcome aura
welcome the leader to her place my
office are currently supporting several
single mothers who continue to struggle
with the child maintenance system
because the support in chasing down
avoiding paying parents or enforcing
repayment of larger years just doesn't
exist in a meaningful way within the
current system will the leader of the
the house ask the new working pension
secretary to give a statement to the
house on improving the existing system
for them and the many single parents
across the uk who are single-handedly
carrying the financial and emotional
burden of raising their children
i thank the honourable lady for raising
this and i will happily pass on her
concerns to the new secretary of state
uh dwp questions are scheduled for the
17th
of october and i would encourage her to
raise that issue in those questions as
well
jim shannon final question mr speaker i
declare an interest as chair of the appg
of pakistan religious minorities and
also as chair of the appg for freedom of
religious belief with that in mind
i know with concern the horrific floods
and devastation and loss of life in
pakistan over the
recent weeks i'm glad to hear of various
initiatives from this government to
deliver aid to help alleviate the impact
of the damage on people's lives
will the leader of the house be able to
allow a statement on the importance of
this aid
reaching all in need in pakistan
particularly those who belong to other
religious groups such as christians and
admires who fear systematic changes
receiving the aid that they very much
need
well he will know historically that uh
the largest uh
share of our aid budget has gone to uh
pakistan and as a consequence we have a
deep and well-informed relationship on
how
that aid money is utilized and i know
that our high commission there will be
ensuring that it is distributed both to
give the maximum positive impact uh for
uh everyone but also to make sure that
there is no discrimination in how it is
distributed
we now come to business the house motion
minister to
move question is the business house
motion that's on the other paper as many
of that opinion say aye
the country know the eyes of it the eyes
of it
before we start the debate i want to put
on record that i am very disappointed
that the written ministerial statement
which is relevant
to it has not yet or just been made
available
in the last five minutes
such statements
should be made available whenever
possible at 9 30 a.m
when they are relevant to the debate
like today it is doubly important that
they are available in good time i'm
sorry this has happened and i consider
it discourteous to the house i hope this
is not the new government in the way
that it intends to treat the house i'm
going to take it down as bad management
or incompetence rather than deliberate
right we now come to the general debate
on uk energy cost
before i call the prime minister to on
the debate i would like to point
customer
[Music]
i don't think that's the day today after
the way this house has been treated i'm
defending you as the backbenchers i
expect a little bit more declaring this
before i call the prime minister to open
the debate i'd like to point out the
british sign language interpretation of
the opening speech in the debate is
available to watch on parliament live tv
i now call the prime minister
[Music]
mr speaker i beg to move the motion
earlier this week
prime minister just one second we
started a bit i don't want any more from
that particular bench if we do i go and
get that cup of tea early prime minister
mr speaker i beg to move the motion
earlier this week i promised i would
deal with the soaring energy prices
faced by families and businesses across
the uk
and today i am delivering on that
promise
this government is moving immediately to
introduce a new energy price guarantee
that will give people certainty on
energy bills
it will curb inflation and boost growth
this guarantee
which includes a temporary suspension of
green levees
means that from the 1st of october
a typical household will pay no more
than 2
500 pounds
per year
for each of the next two years while we
get the energy market back on track
[Applause]
this will save a typical household a
thousand pounds a year
it comes in addition to the 400 pounds
energy bill support scheme
this guarantee supersedes the off-gem
price cap
and has been agreed with energy
retailers
we will deliver this
mr speaker
i will make way in a few minutes when i
have made some progress
mr speaker
we will deliver this by securing the
wholesale price for energy while putting
in place
long-term measures to secure future
supplies at more affordable rates
we are supporting this country through
this winter and next
and tackling the root causes of high
prices so we are never in the same
position again
for those using heating oil
living in park homes or those on heat
networks we will set up a fund so that
all can prime minister sorry about this
can i just say i don't want to run in
commentary from here and giving me the
advice i certainly don't need it promise
i don't want to interrupt it's up to you
to give way when you feel it's
appropriate but just to let you know
that it has now been printed the wms and
i'm hoping that we'll bring into the
chamber for everybody's sake prime
minister
oh thank you thank you mr speaker
for those using heating oil living in
park homes or those on heat networks
we will set up a fund so that all uk
consumers can benefit from equivalent
support
national energy action estimate with the
cap at the current level of six and a
half million households and fuel poverty
so raising the cap to two and a half
thousand pounds how many more millions
of people will end up in fuel poverty
does she reckon
well mr speaker we are taking action to
help people
on the lowest incomes through universal
credit and we are also supplying 400
pounds through the energy bills support
scheme
mr speaker i would like to make some
progress and then i will take more
interventions
we will also support all businesses
charities and public sector
organizations with their energy costs
this winter offering an equivalent
guarantee for six months
after those six months we will provide
further support to vulnerable sectors
such as hospitality including our local
pubs
my right honourable friend the business
secretary will work with business to
review where they should be targeted to
make sure those most in need get support
this review will be concluded within
three months giving businesses certainty
in the meantime companies with the
wherewithal need to be looking for ways
they can improve energy efficiency
and increase direct energy generation i
will give way to my old girlfriend i'm
grateful to the prime minister giving
way and i commend her on the speed with
which she and his new team
can really grip this challenge that's
facing the country and doesn't it
demonstrate mr speaker that conservative
government do not stand by while
millions of people on low incomes are
threatened
[Applause]
well my my honourable friend is
absolutely right
i recognize that people are struggling
with their energy bills and that is why
i have brought forward
this debate as soon as possible to give
people reassurance ahead of this winter
that energy bills are going to be
affordable
and we will be bringing forward
emergency legislation to deliver this
policy
my right honourable friend the
chancellor of the exchequer will set out
the expected costs as part of his fiscal
statement later this month
and i can tell the house today
that we will not be giving in to the
leader of the opposition who calls
who calls for this to be funded through
a windfall tax
that would undermine the national
interest by discouraging the very
investment we need
to secure
[Applause]
will allow me to make a bit more
progress
i may be able to answer their questions
before they've asked them
[Applause]
but mr speaker the party opposite need
to understand prime minister sorry prime
minister appointed order kevin brennan
copies have been made available to some
members of the written ministerial
statement but there aren't enough for
everybody is it possible
if i might if i might finish this point
of order is it possible that
sufficiently so we can all see it
[Applause]
as we both do it's not a point of order
but it's certainly a clarification that
they're now coming out and we're
printing them as fast as possible to
make sure all members have the ability
to read it it is with great
disappointment well that's a matter of
fact prime minister
prime minister
instead
of that approach
we are taking an approach which is
pro-growth
pro-business and pro-the investment we
need for our country's energy security i
will give well very grateful to the
prime minister
does she agree that we are too short of
energy but have plenty of taxes and does
she agree that if we had an oversupply
of taxes as the party opposite wants
we'd have less supply of the things we
were taxing
[Music]
well my my right honourable friend makes
an extremely good point
the reality is we can't tax our way to
growth and the policy i am setting out
today
is all about helping people with their
energy costs as i promised and making
sure that we have the long-term energy
supplies that we need for my our country
i'll give way to the honourable
gentleman at the back
thank you to the prime minister for
giving way
just six months ago
household spaced energy bills of 1 300
pounds we are today being told that
fixing prices at 2 500 pounds is the
best that the government can do it's not
so why is the prime minister putting
private energy profits ahead of people
at this crucial time
well what we are doing is we're doing
the important work to help people
and businesses get through this winter
and next winter whilst fixing britain's
long-term
energy supplies i've already given way a
number of occasions i will give way
later
please hold off for a bit longer
mr speaker
this is the moment to be bold
we are facing a global energy crisis and
there are no cost-free options
there will be a cost to this
intervention
i i strongly welcome this package
a marked contrast to the meager
scrappings offered by the bench's
opposite
and can she i i i just welcome also that
she's confirmed that schools and
colleges will get help with their energy
bills as the colleges faces it face
increases of 300 percent and could i
just finally ask her will she continue
to bear down on fuel duty because we
know that voters at the pumps face
extortionate bills when they fill up
their cars
well i thank i thank my honourable
friend for his point and i'm sure
the chancellor of the exchequer is
listening uh intently to his point ahead
of his fiscal uh statement later this
month
mr speaker i want to make some progress
on explaining
how we will defray the cost of this
intervention which i think might answer
some of the honorable
honourable people's questions before uh
before they ask them
so the way the way we are going to
defray the cost of this intervention is
first of all by ramping up supply
following on from the successful vaccine
task force we have created a new energy
supply task force under the leadership
of maddie mcternan
they are already negotiating new
long-term energy contracts with domestic
and international gas suppliers to
immediately bring down the cost of
intervention
we are also accelerating all sources of
domestic energy
including north sea oil and gas
production
we will be launching a new licensing
round which we expect to lead to over
100 new licenses being awarded
[Applause]
and we will speed up we will speed up
our deployment of all clean and
renewable technologies including
hydrogen solar carbon capture and
storage and wind where we are already a
world leader in offshore generation
renewable and nuclear generations
generators will move on to contracts for
difference to end the situation where
electricity prices are set by the
marginal price of gaps
[Applause]
this will mean that generators are
receiving a fair price reflecting their
cost of production further bringing down
the cost of this intervention i will
give way to my uncle friend
[Applause]
i warmly welcome the immediate action
announced by the prime minister on the
cost of energy which is really going to
help families in the pendle constituency
and right across the united kingdom
next week in parliament is nuclear week
so will she join with me in supporting
the rollout of small modular actors
championed by
rolls royce who have two sites in my
constituency we need this technology now
so will she go further
to drive forward the nuclear program in
this country
well my honorable friend is absolutely
right small modular reactors are a very
important part of our energy mix they
they're produced here in the united
kingdom they will help boost growth as
well as boost our energy
security and secondly i will take a few
more interventions in a few minutes but
please let me make progress on my speech
secondly today's actions will deliver
substantial benefits to our economy
boosting growth which increases tax
receipts and gives certainty to business
this intervention is expected to curb
inflation by up to five percentage
points
bringing a reduction in the cost of
serving servicing government debt
thirdly
i'm announcing today
that with the bank of england we will
set up a new scheme worth up to 40
billion to ensure that firms operating
in the wholesale energy market have the
liquidity they need to manage price
volatility
this will stabilize the market
and decrease the likelihood that energy
retailers need our support like they did
last winter
by increasing supply
boosting the economy and increasing
liquidity in the market we will
significantly reduce the cost to
government of this intervention
[Applause]
very kind of the prime minister to give
way to so many
sensible members
today is clearly a big intervention and
the government is as she promised
wrapping its arms around my constituents
as we did during the pandemic
and looking to the future can she
confirm that the plans are primarily
about domestic supply rather than
imported reliance and therefore in line
with the commitments the important
commitments that we made at cop26 in
glasgow and the path to net zero that we
made in our manifesto three years ago
well i am completely committed to net
zero by 2050 and i'll be saying more
about how we will be achieving that
later on in this speech
[Music]
mr speaker
as well as dealing with the immediate
situation we face
we are also dealing with the root causes
i'll give way to the honorable gentleman
very grateful for privacy wayne can i
welcome her to a place and hope she will
work with opposition parties in the
national interest
but can she confirm
that her announcement today
will still see the energy bills of
struggling families rising by another
500 pounds next month and that this
winter they will be paying energy bills
twice the bills that they paid last
winter
[Music]
well we're also at the same time as
introducing the energy price guarantee
also providing families with 400 pounds
and providing extra support to the
vulnerable so vulnerable families will
be receiving that extra support
but mr speaker i want to move on
to why we are in the situation we are in
now
and the fact is
that energy policy
over the past decades has not focused
enough on securing supply
there is no better
i don't know why
mr speaker i don't know why the
honorable gentleman is laughing he is
partly responsible
there is no better example than nuclear
where the uk has not built a single new
nuclear reactor in 25 years
and it's not just about supply
the regulatory structures have failed
exposing the problems of having a price
cap applied to retail but not to the
wholesale market
all of this has left us vulnerable to
volatile global markets and malign
actors in an increasingly geopolitical
world and that is why
putin
is exploiting this situation by
weaponizing energy supplies as part of
his illegal war on ukraine i'll give way
to honourable gentlemen
would she accept
that with
150 years worth of gas
under the ground in gb
it is absolute madness to turn our back
on that resource at a time when people
are facing huge energy bills and could
she also just um explained to us how she
intends to deliver the support which
she's talking about in northern ireland
well i do agree with the honourable
gentleman i'm coming to the point about
shale gas
in a minute
but i can assure him that this policy
will apply in northern ireland and those
benefits will be open to the people of
northern ireland as part of the united
kingdom
so as well as the action that i am
announcing today
we will use these two years ahead of us
to make sure that the united kingdom is
never in this situation again
[Music]
[Applause]
so i will be launching two reviews
firstly a review of energy regulation to
fix the underlying problems
we want a new approach which will
address supply and affordability for the
long term
secondly
secondly we will conduct a review to
ensure we deliver net zero by 2050 in a
way that is pro-business and pro-growth
and this review will be led by my right
honorable friend the member for
kingswood
can i firstly on behalf of the people of
south leicestershire welcome my
right-hand friend to her role
she mentions putin
whilst the measures that she's
announcing today are incredibly welcome
for my constituents and all our
constituents to protect and particularly
the poorest and most vulnerable in
society
will she give an assurance today
that her government
will continue to stand firm
against the appalling and brutal actions
of putin
and his thuggish regime and will she
tell the british people honestly
that we are in for a difficult winter
notwithstanding the challenges that he
faces
well my my honorable friend is is right
the reason we are in this difficult
situation is because of putin's
appalling war in ukraine but we do need
to make sure that our energy supplies
are more resilient and more secure so we
are never in this situation again
and we cannot be subject to global
energy prices and the actions of
dictators
we are delivering
a stable environment that gives
investors the confidence to back gas as
part of our transition to net zero it is
vital that we take steps to increase our
domestic energy supply i'll make a bit
more progress and then i will give way
we will end the moratorium on extracting
our huge reserves as shale which could
get glass flowing as soon as six months
where there is local support for it
we will launch great british nuclear
later this month
putting us on a path to deliver up to a
quarter of our electricity generation
with nuclear by 2050. i'll give away the
honourable lady
last september i asked the then business
secretary why the government signed off
on the closure of the rough gas storage
facility he dismissed it as not relevant
and he accused me of stoking panicking
an alarm given the government are now
reportedly reopening that facility it
doesn't suggest the new the new
chancellor is a man of foresight and
strategy does it prime minister
we are in a very very difficult
situation and i am committed as prime
minister
to doing everything it takes to resolve
this situation to help people with their
energy bills and to make sure we have
security of supply for the long term
i've already taken a lot of
interventions i need to make progress on
this speech
[Applause]
as a result of these steps on shale and
on nuclear and the acceleration of
renewables i am today setting a new
ambition for our country
far from being dependent on the global
energy market and the actions of malign
actors we will make sure that the uk is
a net energy exporter by 2040
[Music]
and my right honourable friend the
business secretary will set out a plan
in the next two months to make sure we
achieve this
mr speaker
i know that businesses and families are
very concerned about how they will get
through this winter
that is why i felt it was important to
act urgently to provide immediate help
and support
as well as setting out our plan
about how we are going to secure the
uk's future energy supplies
this is part of my vision for rebuilding
our economy
secure energy supply is vital to growth
and prosperity yet it has been ignored
for too long
i will end the uk's short-termist
approach to energy security and supply
once and for all
that is what i promised on the steps of
downing street today we are acting
decisively on that pledge
this will help us build a stronger more
resilient and more secure united kingdom
i commend this motion
[Applause]
there's a lot of members who wish to get
in so think of others
after we've got through the front
benches i know come to leader of the
opposition
[Music]
thank you mr speaker and can i thank the
prime minister for advanced site of our
opening
speech we're in the middle of a national
emergency people are really scared and
families don't know if they can warm
their homes this winter and businesses
ask if they can keep the lights on that
is why the labour party spent the summer
fighting for a price freeze so that no
household would pay a penny more on
their bills
when we called for it many people said
we were wrong
they pretended that this crisis was
something that just affected the poorest
as if working families on average wages
could easily shoulder astronomical bills
they dismissed our call for support as
handouts
but those objections could never last
the prime minister had no choice
no government can stand by while
millions of families fall into poverty
whilst businesses shut their doors and
the economy falls to ruin so i am
pleased there is action today
and that the principle
and the principle of a price limit has
been accepted but under our plan not a
penny more on bills under this plan a
price rise
but this support i'll just make some
progress and then i will but this
support does not come cheap and the real
question before the house today the real
question the government faces the
political question
is who is going to pay
the treasury estimates that energy
producers could make 170
billion pounds in unexpected windfall
profits over the next two years
i repeat that 170
billion pounds in unexpected windfall
profits over the next two years
i will give way in just a moment the
head of bp
has called this crisis a cash machine
for his company
and households are on the other end of
that cash machine their bills funding
these eye-watering profits
that's why we've been calling for a
windfall tax since january
and it's why we want to see the windfall
tax expanded now
but the prime minister
is opposed to win full taxes
she wants to leave these vast profits on
the table
with one clear and obvious consequence
the bill will be picked up by working
people
she claims she claims that a windfall
tax will deter investment
that's ridiculous
these vast promises these vast price
profits are not the reward of careful
planning
they are the unexpected windfall from
putin's barbarity in ukraine
there is no reason why taxing them would
affect investment in the future
don't don't just take my word for it
exactly asked which investment bp would
cancel if there was a windfall tax
the chief executive said
so the prime minister's only argument
against the windfall tax falls apart at
first inspection
laying bare that she simply driven by
dogma
and it's working people that will pay
for that dogma
i will give away
does he accept that this government has
already introduced a windfall tax and
energy companies today are paying six
they're paying 65 percent on their on
their profits what what would he rather
see
that tax set up
we're talking about what happens this
winter and next
and if he doesn't
if he doesn't understand
i'll tell him
every every pound every pound the prime
minister's government refuses to raise
in windfall taxes which is leaving
billions on the table is an extra pound
of borrowing that's the simple
straightforward argument every pound she
leaves on the table is an extra pound of
borrowing
loading the burden of the kosovo in
crisis onto working people who will have
to pay back for years to come
i will
i'm grateful to my right honourable
friend the prime minister has been
careful
to frame
her guarantee
in terms of her refusal to tax
but
is she not going to have a problem
explaining to the british people how a
levy on their bills in the future to
repay the borrowing is not actually a
tax yes
i'm grateful for that intervention this
is the basic political divide
they want to protect the excess profits
of the oil and gas and energy the excess
product
we want to protect working people
mr speaker i will give away i'm very
grateful to him for giving way and
this saturday uh myself and many members
of chesapeake labor party be out meeting
voters in chesterfield and uh if any of
them haven't been paying attention this
week they might still say you're all the
same but isn't it absolutely clear now
that there is a clear divide every voter
that i knock on the door they will know
political parties have a choice they've
chosen to be on the side of the energy
generators we've chosen to be on the
side of build players
well i'm grateful for that and i'll be
absolutely amazed if members opposite
haven't picked this up ask voters
whether they think that it's fair that
they pick up the bill
or those companies that made profits
they didn't expect to make and there's
only one answer to that question it's a
very simple question of whose side are
you on
and i'm afraid this isn't a one-off
because not only is the prime minister
refusing to extend the windfall tax
she is also choosing to cut corporation
tax
an extra 17 billion pounds in tax cuts
for companies that are already doing
well
that means handing a tax cut to the
water companies polluting our beaches
handing tax cuts to the banks having a
tax cut to amazon
she's making that choice
even though households and public
services need every penny they can get
working people are paying for the
positive living crisis stroke victims
wait an hour for an ambulance and
criminals walk the streets with impunity
it's the wrong choice for working people
it's the wrong choice for britain
i thank my right honourable friend and
it seems that the government has decided
to deal with this energy crisis of the
backs of ordinary hard-working bricks
and load huge levels of debt on future
generations rather than properly taxing
the billions of pounds of excess profit
for energy companies
why is this government on the side of
big corporates rather than being on the
side of ordinary hardworking brits is it
because the prime minister is a former
employee of shell and is therefore on
the side of oil and gas companies
and yeah it is not protecting ordinary
working british people
[Applause]
well i'm grateful for that intervention
and it does come down to this basic
point everybody in this house recognizes
that profits are needed for investment
in all businesses
but in this case these are these are
unexpected profits that we're not
expected to make and when the chief
executive of bp says this will not deter
any investment it's a bit rich for the
opposite to say he's completely wrong he
is the chief executive of bp he's made
his case it's the complete opposite of
the case the prime minister is trying to
make
now mr speaker
the immediate cause i will in a moment
the immediate course
of this energy crisis is putin's
grotesque invasion of ukraine
we stand united in our support for
ukraine
if we're to defend democracy defeat
imperialism and preserve security on the
continent
putin's aggression must fail
and whatever our political differences
the prime minister will always have my
full support
in that common endeavor
but we must ask ourselves
why are we so exposed to changes in the
international price of oil and gas
why are we
so at the mercy of dictators able to
pull the plug on wells and shut down
pipelines why is there such a
fundamental flaw in our national
security
i will i will give away in just a moment
i'll make my argument then i will give
way it's about a failure to prepare
a failure to increase our energy
independence a failure to rapidly
decrease our reliance on fossil fuels
they banned mr speaker they banned
onshore wind in 2015.
that cost us clean energy capacity
equivalent to all our russian gas
imports in recent years a policy
disaster
the prime minister has been constantly
opposed to solar power the cheapest form
of energy that we have
and she's been consistently wrong
and it's not just what the prime
minister said in the heat of her
leadership campaign this summer
when she was environment secretary the
government slashed solar subsidies the
market crashed i will give away people
to the right honourable gentleman but
the leader of the opposition
has been completely misleading if i may
say so because what he said
it's under this government that the
united kingdom has the second highest
offshore wind generation capacity
anywhere in the world
and how is that created it's through
investment by companies this government
will allow for that to happen
well i take it from that intervention
that he doesn't quarrel with me that the
ban on onshore wins since 2015 has been
a policy disaster
along with the opposition to solar power
i i forgive me i saw the former prime
minister raising i will take her
intervention of course
thank you i'm grateful to the right
honourable gentleman for giving way he's
talking about lack of preparation for
energy security for the united kingdom
in that case if his labour is so worried
about lack of preparation why did they
not build any new nuclear capacity
[Applause]
mr speaker i i'm great
i'm grateful for that intervention let
me deal with it in full because it's a
very important point because nuclear is
vital to our future and a new generation
of power plants should have been built
by now
yesterday the prime minister tried
desperately to blame labor and that
intervention goes to this point i
remember
i remember the exchange across this
dispatch box in 20 2006
in which prime minister blair said
i'm a pro-nuclear
and the leader of the opposition the
leader of the opposition david cameron
didn't know where to look
if you haven't seen the clip have a look
i'm pro-nuclear david cameron didn't
know where to look
the uncomfort the
the uncomfortable truth for members
opposite is this
the last labor government gave the go
ahead for new nuclear sites in 2009
in the 13 long years since then not one
has been completed
[Music]
let me turn to home insulation
which
i will give away
um tony blair may have said he was
pro-nuclear but he didn't actually build
any nuclear power
but let me let me let me ask him let me
let me ask him about the windfall tax
the 170 billion pounds he talks about
from my understanding most of that
is not profit
of uk companies it's energy supplied to
the united kingdom but it's not within
our ability to tax it secondly we
already have a windfall tax we're
already taxing those profits at 65
how high does he want a windfall tax to
[Music]
go the question of 2006 i think i'll
i'll give way to him again what was his
party's position in 2006 when david
cameron was asked the question on
nuclear because he didn't have a
position on it but on the 170 billion
that he raises i think he's wrong about
that but if there is any doubt if there
is any doubt i'd invite the treasury to
disclose the documents about this so
that we can all see them and evaluate
them because i think i'm right and i
think he's wrong but if the documents
could be made available we can all look
at that 170 billion pound
mr speaker
i will give way
but isn't the bigger point
that there's a simple choice about how
you pay for it yeah it either all goes
on borrowing
and what ordinary families and on the
never never for this country
or at least some of it is charged in a
windfall tax on unearned and unexpected
income which putin has basically put
into the
into the pockets of shell and bp that's
the fundamental choice isn't it
that is the fundamental choice is the
fundamental divide in this house
let them defend their position to
protect those excess profits and we will
defend our position of standing up for
working people
let me i'm going to make some progress
i'm going to make some progress
mr speaker i've taken a lot of
intervention i'm going to make some
progress let me turn to home insulation
which reduces energy consumption like
nothing else we have the draftiest homes
in europe the last labor government set
about fixing that
then the party opposite said cut the
green crap and the whole project all but
collapsed
installation rates down by 92 percent
utterly
and it's costing millions of households
a thousand pounds a year on their energy
bills right now
the prime minister is right to recognize
that immediate support needs to be
combined with longer-term action but i'm
afraid fracking on a dash for gas in the
north sea will not cut bills
nor strengthen our energy security but
they will drive a coaching horses
through our efforts to fight the looming
climate crisis
she should listen to her own chancellor
sitting next to her
what
did the chancellor have to say about
this just a few months ago
now this is quite a long quote see the
chancellor leaning forward i've tried to
cut it down
but every sentence is worth repeating of
what the chancellor said just a few
months ago his words
for those calling for its return they
misunderstand the situation we find
ourselves in
if we lifted the fracking moratorium it
would take up to a decade to extract
sufficient volumes
and it would come at a high price for
communities and our precious countryside
his words i'll go on because this is so
good
second he said second he said just a few
months ago
no amount of shale gas from hundreds of
wells dotted across rural england would
be enough to lower the european price
anytime soon
and he went on
and with the best will in the world
private companies are not going to sell
shale gas they produce to uk consumers
below the market price
they are not charities
spot on chancellor
and what did
what did the chance at the same time
have to say about north sea gas
additional north sea production won't
materially affect the wholesale price
indeed earlier this year his previous
department helpfully put out a series of
mythbusters a government
extracting more north sea gas lowers
prices
answer
fact uk production isn't large enough to
materially impact or the global price of
gas
i've got a copy for the prime minister
we do need to carefully manage our
existing resources in the north sea
and the industry has an important role
to play in our future as we transition
to a different form of energy but
doubling down on fossil fuels is a
ludicrous answer to a fossil fuel crisis
and if all countries took the approach
advocated by our new energy secretary of
squeezing every single drop out of their
fossil fuel reserves
global temperatures will rise by a
catastrophic three degrees
that will be devastating
for our planet and future generations
and it's totally unnecessary now i'm
going to make some progress because i do
think other speakers need to get in
new wind and solar power are now nine
times cheaper than gas nine times
cheaper
so we need a clean energy sprint
urgently accelerating the roll out of
offshore wind onshore wind solar nuclear
hydrogen and tidal
and last year i set out a new national
mission to insulate 19 million homes and
cut bills for good
if the government had taken me up on
that challenge two million homes would
already be insulated this winter
britain needs a fresh start we need a
government that will never leave working
people to pick up the tab
for excess profits of the energy
industry we need a government that plans
for the long term rather than leaving us
badly exposed to the whims of dictators
and we need a government that will drive
us forward to energy independence rather
than doubling down on fossil fuels
the change we need is not the fourth
tory prime minister in six years it's a
labor government
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker
and i refer the house to my entry in the
members register can i first of all
congratulate my right honourable friend
on acting so swiftly to bring forward a
package of support for people with their
energy bills there's no doubt as every
member of this house knows that this is
a matter of real concern for people in
my constituency and every other
constituency who've been concerned about
how they're going to keep their homes
and indeed businesses worried about how
they can continue to run their
businesses
my also welcome the fact that my right
honourable friend has coupled action on
energy bills with action on energy
security the vicious further invasion of
ukraine by russia has indeed shown the
necessity of us having our own energy
security although it makes sense anyway
we have made important progress in this
over recent years i refer of course to
the investment in hinckley point c
and i uh again welcome the commitment
that my right honourable friend and the
government have made to continuing that
commitment uh to support nuclear energy
and as i pointed out in my intervention
just just wait a second
more than one second
as i pointed out in my intervention to
the right honourable leader of the
opposition and was emphasized by the
excellent intervention by my right
honourable friend the member the forest
of dean in 13 years of government
whatever the then leader of the labour
party might have said they did not build
any new
capabilities
i thank her for giving way on hinckley
point c is going to be at least four
years late possibly five years late it's
still a fifty percent over budget in edf
i've got now water and 35 year contract
for a straight rate at 92 pounds 50 per
megawatt compared to roughly 40 pounds
per megawatt for just 15 years an
onshore uh on onshore and offshore wind
she should have scrapped hinckley points
even through the turn shouldn't she
[Music]
can i say to the honorable gentleman
it's high time that scottish
nationalists actually came up with some
practical solutions
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i'm very grateful to the former prime
minister you know we're all trying to
find energy security can i say to her
and say to the government front bench
what we should be doing is prioritizing
tidal there's an excellent royal society
deport from last year that indicates we
can get to eleven and a half gigawatts
i'm asking the government to enhance the
ring fence pot from 20 to 50 million
you'll get the best load you need and
you won't need nuclear energy
say to the right honourable gentleman
this is actually a rather strange point
in my political career because i
actually agree with him
[Laughter]
that when i was prime minister i looked
very closely over a significant period
of time at proposals particularly for
the seven estuary uh and unfortunately
that time the price that would was too
high
of course looking at it today it could
be a very different uh very different
picture
now my right honourable friend outlined
a number of steps that the government is
taking and i look forward to seeing the
full details of these but i would like
to suggest there are some other measures
which will address energy prices and
energy security while capitalizing on
our high growth tech sectors and would
also help us to meet our domestic and
international climate change obligations
because there are measures that will
save people money that will also help to
save the planet the uk has already shown
that you don't have to choose between
low emissions and economic growth you
can have both
to achieve net era we will need to
remove the country's dependence on
fossil fuels my right honourable friend
announced a net zero review
perhaps when he sums up this debate the
secretary of state could indicate how
that net zero review will fit in with
the net zero strategy which the
government published in advance of cop
26 and which many are already working on
so my while my writing real friend has
acted swiftly and correctly to help
people over these difficult times it
does make sense to accelerate our
transition to a low-carbon energy system
that can be done by in just a moment
that can be done by speeding up the roll
out of low-cost homegrown renewable
technologies correctly
but the government's cases that energy
prices are going up because of the war
in ukraine therefore these profits are
being earned because of the war
in ukraine why is it right to prioritize
war profiteering and instead of a
stealth tax on households
what is right is to provide support for
households who are worried about their
energy
[Applause]
of course if we are going to increase
our use of renewals and it is important
that the price that people are paying
for their electricity reflects the cost
of that production and not the cost of
gas and i welcome again the fact that my
right honourable friend now i am going
to make i'm going to make
i'm going to make some progress i'm
going to make some progress on it
can i say to my right honourable friend
that i'm pleased that she's actually
indicated that she's
going to take action on relation to that
particular matter can i also say that
getting full benefit from this does mean
upgrading the uk's power grid
infrastructure
alongside this we do need to improve the
efficiency energy efficiency of homes
and
this would not just reduce demand for
energy saving people money but again
it's an element that will help to save
the planet we do need to consider
rolling out a significant home
insulation program
there is also like well i'll give way to
my honourable friend and then i'll give
away
i'm very grateful to my right honourable
friend her government did indeed look
very closely at the prospect of a tidal
lagoon of swansea bay and at that time
it is quite correct as she says that it
was too expensive although the price now
looks relatively attractive but does she
agree with me that actually the real
opportunity at the moment which the
current chancellor has been very
supportive of when he was a base is for
marine energy to come from tidal stream
which the new renewable auction is
supporting but there is much more that
can be done especially if we can affect
the planning regulations around the
pipeline of opportunity does she agree
that there is more this government could
do on that yeah yes i absolutely agree
with my honourable friend and i welcome
every opportunity to actually increase
the diversity of our supply of energy
and looking at these new opportunities
is absolutely a way to do that as well i
said i would give way to the right one
very grateful and of course i completely
support the title lagoon in swansea and
i hope that that is now a real
possibility for us i hope the prime
minister would accept that and but i
just want to and i agree with her about
in insulation
i think i understood the prime minister
to say earlier that there was going to
be protection for public services for
just six months
and many local authorities hospitals
schools are facing dramatically
increased bills already
aren't they going to need more support
than just six months
sector will be very pleased to hear that
the government has taken their concerns
on board and is providing support for
them
uh can i also say is another step that i
think the government needs to take it
should look at regulations uh building
regulations
we are still building homes with gas
boilers
uh doesn't it make sense to actually
change the regulations because those
homes will have to be retrofitted in
just a very few years time and surely it
is more cost effective to take action
i i'm very
before the only resemblance of that bond
intervention what i'm both about is a
lot of people want to get it i don't
want to stifled a bit but i want to make
sure everybody gets a voice yes i i
apologize mr speaker for being generous
in interventionism
uh the government is also key to driving
greater private sector investment in
low-carbon solutions for instance by
de-risking investment into early-stage
technologies we've already heard about
some early-stage technologies and
emerging sectors such as hydrogen
production greater investor certainty
costs the cost of new technology drives
innovation creates jobs and boosts
economic growth
and the government's unequivocal support
for this agenda would be a positive
signal not just for our green tech
industry but for the ambition of the uk
economy more broadly now people no i'm
just about finished so people need help
with their bills today that is what the
government is providing but britain led
the world through the industrial
revolution if we grasp the opportunity
now we can lead the world in a cleaner
greener form of growth
we now come to the leader of the smp ian
blackford
thank you mr speaker can i say it's a
it's a pleasure to follow the
former prime minister the right
honourable
member for maidenhead and if i can just
reflect back very briefly on the way
that she behaved when she was prime
minister and i have to say the courtesy
that she showed to opposition leaders
whether it was the then leader of the
labour party or ourselves as a third
party and if i can gently say to the
prime minister that some of the
protocols of making sure that we had
advanced site of of statements is
important and indeed that we're aware of
when the prime minister would be coming
to the chamber to speak
um i don't know if she's listening to
any of that but it would be helpful if
that would be passed on
mr speaker at the
start of the year we were faced with an
energy crisis
by the summer it was an emergency
right now today
we're at the precipice of a humanitarian
disaster
because
it's no longer a question of whether to
heat or eat
when many households can no longer
afford to do either with the honourable
gentleman
let me make some progress on it and i
will this cost crisis puts livelihoods
and lives at risk
and all the while
as this disaster deepened all summer the
tories spent all their time
desperately fighting amongst themselves
and the public were left desperately
waiting for a real cost of living plan
we finally finally have a plan today but
i fear that when the public absorb the
details it will fall far short of what
helped you need
now we've heard today that the green
levees
are being scrapped and that is something
that is of deep concern to those of us
on these benches particularly given that
the green levees fund the warm discount
scheme and of course energy efficiency
measures for low-income households and i
want to ask the government to make sure
that that support will remain in place
for those that need it but mr speaker
the sheer scale of those soaring energy
bills meant that there was never any
question that households and businesses
couldn't be able to pay the cost of
energy bills they were and they are
unaffordable if these prices weren't
frozen the bill simply couldn't have
been paid
so
freezing prices wasn't really a choice
it's the only political option
and when the current price cap stands at
2 000 pounds with a 54 increase in
spring and many people are already
unable to pay
setting the cap at 2 500 pounds isn't an
actual freeze
we know too that businesses especially
smes are facing even sharper cost
increases than households and an
avalanche of insolvencies and
redundancies
many businesses simply could not have
afforded to stay open i will give them
mr speaker i thank the right arm
gentleman for giving way
reed's bakery in my constituency which
supplies biscuits to the four corners of
the world
is in danger of going bust by christmas
so can i appeal to the government in a
spirit of inclusivity to please look at
the letter i've been sent by reed's
bakery and to see what could be tailored
to help a vital business in a row part
of the uk
i i agree with
my honourable friend my my neighboring
mp and indeed over the course of the
last few weeks i've visited
businesses in asia with my honourable
friend the member for for tomorrow who
visited another bakery brownings and
met with the the industry body and it's
clear that bakers in particular are
facing real struggles with the rise of
energy and other costs and it's critical
that the government gives the details of
what they're intending to support
business i'll take one more intervention
than all of you i'm grateful to the
right honourable gentleman on the
question of the cap the prime minister
indicated that one of our reviews is
going to be on regulation
does the right honourable gentleman
think it's time to take a serious look
at the operations of off gem and for a
radio how much support they're giving to
consumers whether it's domestic
consumers or businesses
i think it's fair to say that the
current regime is not fit for purpose
and it's why we're in the situation that
we are today so an urgent review of that
is absolutely required mr speaker let me
let me make some progress
good businesses profitable businesses
seeing a tsunami of cost increases with
energy costs at the core of these quite
simply are facing a fight for survival
it is clear that today's plan does not
go nearly far enough to mitigate the
expected cost increase facing employers
and the uk government needs to grasp the
scale of this emergency
i will say something about the
announcement which has just been made
about her majesty i know i speak on
behalf of the entire house when i say
that we send our best best wishes to a
majesty the queen and that she and the
royal family are in our thoughts and
prayers at this moment i'm going to take
no more just to if there is anything
else we will up the house accordingly
thank you in blackfood yeah yeah thank
you mr speaker and i'm sure on behalf of
all colleagues that we're saddened to
hear the announcement that's been made
and the thoughts and prayers
of all of us will be with her majesty
the queen and indeed with the royal
family
mr speaker
in reality
the one big political question the real
question was how today's plan would be
paid for
and who would pay for it
and ever since the
new prime minister took office we've
been waiting for these answers
but after all the waiting
it couldn't be any clearer
she set it out
very brazenly
the prime minister's plan
means that the public pays
she has made the political choice
to tax families instead of companies
to put profit
over people
instead of a win for tax
she's chosen a new tory tax
the trust tax
the trust tax that means that in the
months and years ahead households and
businesses will be punished with higher
bills
higher interest rates
and higher mortgage costs a trust tax
means it cuts to the vital public
services people rely on and which are
used to support the most vulnerable
a trust tax
means a threat to the scottish budget
which the scottish government is using
to protect our population and shield
workers and public services as best they
can
i will i will give way i will give me
i'm grateful to the honourable gentleman
for giving away he seems to be making an
argument for a windfall tax on the oil
and gas companies and given that the
leader of the opposition wasn't able to
answer this question we already appear
that they already appear 65 on their
profits what would he rather see that
that tax setter
i'm grateful for that intervention and
if he just bears with me i'm going to
come to that very specific point but
that issue of who pays is important
because there is no well actually i will
do and you might actually show some
respect if you don't mind because at the
end of the day
oil and gas producers are making
windfall profits our constituents his
constituents are suffering
and it's right
mr speaker that we look at the
contribution that those making win for
profits will make and i won't i will
come to that i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna make a little bit of progress
because i'm conscious that others want
to get in
mr speaker the frightening bit for
people is that the new prime minister
made this choice
on day one in the job yeah because on
day one
we saw the pound slip to a low not seen
since the thatcher years knocked by the
uk's worsening economic outlook
on day one
our first major decision as prime
minister will see big business profits
prioritized over family budgets and on
day one
we can already predict that the trust
tax paid for by households for the years
to come will be the prime minister's
enduring legacy eating away at household
budgets long after she and her party
have been voted out of office
if day one was that bad
you couldn't blame people for feeling
that the worst is yet to come
mr speaker the decision not to bring in
an additional windfall tax is the
biggest
and the worst political choice in this
plan
because let's look at shell and bp as an
example now i want corporates to be able
to be profitable to invest
to create jobs and to finance a green
transition
but there is a difference between a fair
profit and an excess windfall or excess
profit
mr speaker
shell's first half profits were up by
177
percent to 25.2
billion dollars
shell were making excess profits
to such an extent
they brought back shares worth 8.5
billion dollars and declared that they
would buy back a further six billion
dollars worth of shares between july and
september if you want the example of
where the excess profit is mr speaker
then there it is
in total
this means
this means that 14.5 billion dollars of
excess profits not being invested in
green energy projects money that's been
generated from high energy prices that
our constituents and our businesses have
to pay that is the reality
then let's take a look at british
petroleum quarter two profits up from
3.1 billion dollars to 9.2 and a shared
buyback for this quarter of 3.5 billion
dollars
you know mr speaker quite frankly that
will disgust our constituents that that
money has been given back to
shareholders at a time that people quite
simply can't afford to put their heat
away
these are global corporates but we can
and should fairly tax their uk
activities so why on earth
why on earth is the prime minister
failing to bring in a fair windfall tax
why are ordinary people right across
these islands ultimately going to have
to float these bills
why does her plan
not address that real issue mr speaker
this energy plan
is not only defined by the choice it
makes to make the public pay instead of
the excess profits of massive
corporations
it is also defined by its glaring
emissions
because
there is no proper plan
to help those that are already
struggling
support needs to be targeted to
low-income households and those
negatively impacted by spiraling costs
such as unpaid carers larger households
and disabled people
in scotland we're already prioritizing
this support to the most vulnerable the
scottish government
is doing what it can
freezing reds banning evictions freezing
train fares expanding three school meals
to primary six and primary seven that's
a government acting with compassion
[Applause]
i'd like to thank my honourable friend
for making the most valid point
that the working people across these
islands will be paying for generations
to come for this borrowing for excess
greed described by the un secretary
general is utterly grotesque and immoral
to be making excess profits on the back
of fossil fuels and what i've heard from
this government today is more of the
same was the question i want to ask is
has the government put any conditions
despite their ideology that profits must
be made regardless if they put any
conditions on these exercise profits on
what they're going to do an investment
to a rapid transition so it saves all
our future generations from the climate
catastrophe
my honourable friend is absolutely right
and you know in the context of this
we're doing what we can with the
devolved powers that we have and let me
say to the government that one of the
things that we have done is introduce
the game-changing scottish child payment
which will be increased to 25 pounds a
week
lifting 50 000 children in poverty yeah
out of poverty in scotland
i need to make progress but we're all
too aware that this is nowhere else to
mitigate the effects of this crisis
because most of the key economic levers
lie here at westminster
so
if the new prime minister
is serious about helping everyone
through this winter she should at the
very least
lift universal credit
by 25 pounds a week
first i welcome the remarks of the
prime minister on those on off grid we
must be given clarity over support for
those across swathes of rural scotland
who rely on oil heating and who are not
subject to the price cap
clarity is also needed to those who have
accepted fixed term contracts at a
higher rate in a bid to weather the
storm they must be allowed to switch to
benefit from the support that's been put
in place and crucially vital support for
the most vulnerable must go hand in hand
with the uk government to increase
budgets of the devolved administrations
or grant them greater powers to borrow
so that they can do more to help all
public service workers and the most
vulnerable
i'm grateful to the right honourable
gentleman who's making a a very broad
and apathetic speech
he was challenged on the rate of tax
that he believed was appropriate but of
course he will also know that prior to
the introduction of the windfall tax the
uk had the lowest tax rate of any oil
and gas
producer in the world
65
which is what he was uh challenged on is
actually six percentage points below the
average of all producers in the world so
even even if you were
even if you were prepared to go to the
global average
it would still it would still mean that
relief could be given to taxpayers in
this country
that the the honourable gentleman makes
an awful lot of sense with his
intervention and what we should be
reflecting on
is that these are oil and gas companies
that are making additional profits not
because they're improving their
businesses not because they're investing
but quite simply because the oil and gas
prices are higher and it's quite right
in the context of that
that our consumers our businesses are
compensated why an airs
are we sitting back
allowing the oil and gas companies to
engage in billions and billions of
dollars of shared buybacks mr speaker i
want to make progress because i'm
conscious of the
time and those that want to speak
i want to
briefly deal with another prominent
point in the prime minister's speech
because
the prime minister blames the cost of
living crisis on the war in ukraine and
i believe that this issue is worth
expanding on and of course
there is no doubting
that what has happened in ukraine has
had a major role in spiraling wholesale
prices and we have rightly
come together across this chamber in
condemnation of putin's horrific war and
his actions to thwart european energy
supply and i look forward
to continuing to work with the new
government
in a spirit of consensus on this issue
we all stand together against putin's
horrible actions the war in ukraine
but
as we've rightly helped ukraine
we must also help citizens at home
indeed we owe it to them to do so and i
would hope that the prime minister will
reach consensus with me on this point
but where we divide
it's what i believe we must recognize
that other countries in europe far more
reliant on russian gas in the uk have
weathered the economic storm far better
than the united kingdom
and we must therefore recognize the uk
government's role in creating the
circumstances for this crisis
shameful mismanagement by a successive
tory government stopped by a tory brexit
means at the uk has the highest
inflation in the g7
the lowest growth in the g20 and we're
marching headlong into a recession
uk household electricity prices have
surged ahead of european peers and the
uk is now in a deeper state of crisis
than most because of the damaging
choices
that have been made we don't need it
i thank the honorable gentleman for
giving way
does he share my view that for my
constituents in north ayrshire and
ireland the most important aspect of
this announcement today is that as they
are waiting to hear of help
with their fuel bills
as they live in difficulty what they've
been told today is that their fuel bills
will rise and they will be bitterly
disappointed by this and nothing has
been offered to them today does he agree
with that disappointment yes i do and of
course we need to reflect that these
energy bills in scotland are rising in
an energy rich scotland yeah and the
damage of the choices that the uk
government has made choices that have
been imposed upon us
make the choice of scotland's future
ever clearer
because scotland is energy rich we
simply shouldn't be facing an urgency
emergency mr deputy speaker it may
surprise some in this house but scotland
produces six times more gas than we
consume
and almost 100
of our entire electricity production
comes from renewables that's not
attention-seeking prime minister these
are the facts
scotland has the energy
we just simply don't have the powers
we are stuck
in a uk market that prices our
electricity based on the price of
wholesale gas and the power to change
the system lies with westminster
i thank you for giving way and of course
he'll also know that although we are
producing almost 100 percent of our
energy from renewable sources
the grid connection charges that are
seven pounds 36 per megawatt compared to
40 pence per megawatt hour in england
doesn't help further investment we need
these credit connection charges to be
reduced because my constituents want to
know when they can see wind milk or wind
turbines outside their windows why are
their prices going up
well again my honorable friend makes a
very very important point we've been
ripped off
on scotland's ability to deliver green
renewable energy but it's even worse
than that
because for those of us that live in the
north of scotland because we have a
regional distribution market we pay a
premium for the electricity that was
sent south we then have to pay the
highest prices to get it back
that's the cost of people in scotland or
westminster's control of our energy
market
so what is needed most crucial of all
and what is glaringly lacking in this
energy plan is fundamental overhaul of
the energy market to break the link
between cost of gas and the price of
renewable and low carbon electricity the
reality mr mr deputy speaker is that an
independent and an energy-rich scotland
with the normal powers to act on our own
interests could have cushioned our
economy from this cost-of-living crisis
through independence scotland could use
our energy well for the benefit of our
people so for households and businesses
in scotland the cost of living crisis is
literally the cost of living with
westminster it is a cost we can no
longer afford and it is a price we are
no longer willing to pay it's why
scotland's people will choose
independence
[Applause]
there's a lot of uh interest in this
debate uh so therefore we're introducing
forthwith a three-minute uh time limit
robin walker thank you mr deputy speaker
and i welcome the prime minister and
indeed all her colleagues to their
places on the front bench and the rapid
action that has been announced today i
wanted to
see action for consumers in my
constituency but also
for businesses for charities in the
public sector and i'm delighted to hear
all of that included in today's
statement over the summer i've heard
from hundreds of constituents about
their concerns people who are vulnerable
elderly students and people with
illnesses and disabilities which mean
that they weren't able to turn down
their heating in the upcoming winter so
the action which has been announced
today will be extremely welcome in all
of those quarters the fact that there is
a two-year cap in place uh particularly
uh welcome in my constituency but i've
also been hearing from businesses
and i've been very very concerned at
some of the costs facing
pubs hospitality businesses
manufacturers in my constituency indeed
as long as goes last year i was writing
to event business secretary now
chancellor about high energy
manufacturers such as aluminium
extrusions businesses superform
and aeromatim in my constituency and
about some of our largest manufacturers
worcester bosch
and mazak and the impact of energy costs
on them so i'm delighted that today's
announcement also means help for
businesses with energy and of course
that help for businesses with energy is
also my long-term help for consumers i
look forward to hearing more about the
urgent work going on uh to support the
hospitality sector which is so important
uh in all of our constituencies and even
retailers have been affected uh by these
issues i was hearing from a wonderful
independent retailer in worcester toys
and games of worcester uh that their
energy bills were going up by as much as
uh 400 they expected later on this year
i i hope that this intervention today
will mean that that does no longer
happens and that business can continue
to thrive i'm delighted as a former
schools minister uh to hear of the help
for schools i know some of the
challenges that they face uh with energy
pressures and i think it's vital that we
help them to address those uh i do think
the intervention on that front is is
vital and important and of course for
charities as well in the last week i
visited uh my wonderful hospice in
worcestershire richards and this week
i'll be visiting the children's hospice
i know both of them were concerned about
the impact of energy pills so we've seen
correct interventions in all of those
spaces much to welcome in this statement
the new energy supply task force uh the
speeding up of deployment of clean
technologies including crucially
hydrogen the reduction in inflation by
up to five percentage points and the new
bank of england scheme to support
liquidity in the wholesale market a
review to ensure net zero can be met in
a way that supports businesses pro
growth which i'm delighted to hear is
taking place under my honourable friend
and sometimes look alike for kingswood
uh so i i welcome this statement uh i i
want to make sure uh but we go further
and and particularly i would urge
ministers to consider the opportunities
of hydrogen in helping us to make sure
we can continue to deliver gas central
heating to our constituents home in a
clean low-cost and energy efficient way
clive effort thank you mr deputy speaker
although the solutions to this crisis
may sound complicated in this debate the
choice is straightforward for the
government who pays at the end of the
day and let's be clear what a winful tax
is it's not taxing the profits of energy
companies that they had planned for and
that could be expected in all reason
this is a windfall that has come about
as the government has said itself as a
consequence of what is happening in the
ukraine the aggression by putin and the
question that i have and that my
constituents will have is how can the
government reasonably come to a
conclusion that it is okay for those
energy companies to make these huge
profits on the back of that aggression
by puting and this is not as if it's a
windfall for the government this is
going to cost the taxpayer through the
government no matter what we do over the
windfall tax and the government is under
pressure in other areas of expenditure
we only have to look at the newspapers
today about the yet again the numbers of
people waiting for operations in the nhs
has gone up again to 6.8 million people
waiting we've seen we can see in the
papers today about
the teachers assistance in schools where
they they are being forced because of
the cost of living to question whether
they can stay committed to supporting
children in the schools and move to
higher paid jobs in places like
supermarkets
everything where you look the government
is under pressure of a public
expenditure on our vital public services
yet when it comes to this they're
prepared to just wave aside the
potential to pay for these increases
thank you mr speaker i'm grateful that
he mentions the case of teaching
assistants because i actually had a
teaching assistant contact me recently
and there are many many low paid workers
and many others on moderate income so
we'll be staggered by the government's
decision today to put the interests of
energy companies ahead of normal
families absolutely my honourable friend
is is absolutely right and so the the
government is morally
wrong to turn its back on the this
windfall tax when it clearly is under
financial pressure in other areas of
public
expenditure but i wanted to raise just
one specific issue relating to my
constituency this brief
contribution i can make to this debate
and it's i have a craft bakery that has
uh survived for a 100 years it's about
to celebrate its centenary it's been run
by six generations of the same family it
kept feeding people in my constituency i
wasn't the mp at the time
but during the they're in the second
world war so even the luftwaffe couldn't
shut down uh this this uh bakery it
employs 20 uh members of staff and now
it's trying to renegotiate
in a industry that is really heavy in
you in the use of energy it is trying to
renegotiate its energy contracts and it
is facing
increases in those contracts of three
four hundred percent and it's negotiated
them now and in the statement that we've
had published and that's it by the way
that's the sheer length of this
statement in this uh this important
crisis that's the amount of the
government's statement today there are
but with 200 words
they are facing negotiations now but
this statement says that there will be
assistance equivalent to that given to
individuals for uh for
for um businesses guaranteed for six
months
and the
prime minister i wrote the words down
said that businesses would be given some
idea of what systems they will get
in three months well they're negotiating
now
i mean we got no clarity from the prime
minister in her statement it was like
she was making a queen speech my
government will but she gave us no
detail
on actually what these government
ministers will be doing and one of the
things i want to guarantee on is if
we're going to get a financial statement
from the government next week or we or
towards the end of the uh of this
session before we we break again for
conferences will there be a proper
debate in here on that financial
statement as we're required to have or
will the government avoid scrutiny yet
again because that's been a repeated
action
mel stride
the speaker and i rise to broadly
welcome
these measures
we know that we live in terribly
difficult times yesterday the treasury
committee took evidence from the
governor of the bank of england and
other members of the npc and the point
was made that the impact of these
energy rises on households is about four
times that which occurred in the 1970s
these are truly frightening times and so
i'm very pleased that my writable friend
uh the prime minister's come forward
with such a bold package of measures um
both for uh consumers but also
critically uh for businesses over the
next uh six months with a review after
three i was pleased to see the bank of
england facility the liquidity facility
for energy businesses totaling 40
billion which i think would be very
important in terms of the functioning of
the marketplace and also this critical
commitment to review the way in which uh
the pricing of our electricity is
determined uh whether it be in relation
to uh gas or the actual underlying costs
of alternative means of energy uh
production i did want to uh focus
briefly uh mr a deputy speaker uh on the
macroeconomic issues here which are easy
to overlook this is a huge intervention
the prime minister uh detailed that uh
the chancellor would come forward with
those costings at the emergency uh
fiscal event that he is to uh present to
the house uh soon now that in terms uh
including uh or alongside should i say
the tax reductions that have been uh
muted um plus the other uh pressures on
the public finances mean that debt is
most certainly going to increase as is
the deficit and whilst it has been
stated that inflation will be assisted
by these measures which is true
inflation of course is just a measure of
price rises relative to a previous
period at a particular point in time and
whilst it may be the case that uh the
downward pressure on the cbr uh cpi uh
from these uh these freezes uh will be
will be positive it will be a stimulus
to the economy and through time mr
deputy speaker
inflation may actually
net uh increase now that will require a
response from
our central bank which may seem increase
interest rates in the more medium term
increasing with increased servicing uh
costs uh for our debt so i think we need
to see this very much in the round and
this is where i think this debate around
the windfall tax actually should be at
least considered and the treasury
committee will be looking at that in
some detail the final point i wish to
make in my remaining 30 seconds is i
think it's critical that when it comes
to the emergency fiscal event we do have
an obr independent forecast to take into
account all of these issues the great
uncertainty that we're talking about
these huge fiscal interventions which
have yet uh the costings have not been
presented to us we need to see what the
impact of that is going to be on the
public finances in order to reassure the
markets thank you carolyn harris
thank you mr deputy speaker um
everyone will be affected by the rise in
energy prices all looking for ways to
cut back by being more careful about the
appliance we use or often for
alternative ways to keep warm and
prepare meals it's a worrying time for
many of my constituents in swan's east
and for the others the length and
breadth of the country but for some the
worry and the fear are even greater over
sixty thousand people across the uk are
in need of renal replacement therapy in
the form of dialect dialysis or a
transplant as is my daughter no hayley
is one of those hayley suffers from
kidney failure and has done since she
was 11. a transplanted 15 gave her seven
years of freedom but for the last 11
years she's been back on dialysis
home dialysis allows hayley to spend
more time with her family and has even
given her the opportunity to attend
university and to go to work rather than
spending three days a week in hospital
but running the machine for 10 days 10
hours at a time six nights a week comes
at a price
the approximate cost for electricity to
run the home dialysis machine is almost
80 pound per month at present and with
energy prices set to soar these costs
are only going to increase threatening
manny's patients ability to continue
their life-saving treatment at home
charity kidney care uk and the pop and
kidney support in my constituency have
both recently contacted me about their
concerns for patients and the lack of
support they have been offered by energy
providers
in wales patients like hayley are
reimbursed by the welsh renal clinic
network but with the cost of extra
energy needed for home dialysis machines
expected to increase to two thousand
pound a year the level of financial
support will fall far short
and the situation is even worse in other
parts of the country where reimbursement
amounts vary considerably with some
patients receiving no help at all
the cost of kidney failure and other
chronic conditions should not should not
be borne by patients and it's not only
dialysis patients who affected many
people depend on home electrical medical
equipment oxygen concentrators
nebulizers artificial ventilators
stairlifts bed and bath coasts add to
this the additional cost for heating and
lighting and many vulnerable people are
feeling the pain of this winter
no one should be in a position where
they have to cut down use on this vital
equipment for fear of paying their bills
so for my daughter-in-law and for all
the all the hailey's out there who were
looking at uncomfortable increases and
unaffordable increases can the
government ensure that sufficient
finance financial support is made
available to cover these essential
electrical medical equipment
scope of my comments brief given the
time available um can i just uh ask the
minister in the energy update the
written statement that was published
there was confirmation and the prime
minister confirmed this as well that the
chancellor will set out the expected
costs
as part of the fiscal statement can i
ask if
those costs will include the
government's assumptions of how
wholesale prices are going to move over
the coming months and years yes it's an
estimate but you have to make some
assumptions to calculate the cost and
secondly and importantly will the
estimates of the costs of this package
be independently scored by the office
for budget responsibility or will they
simply be the government's assessment of
costs it'd be helpful if the minister
winding up the debate could confirm
which of those two it will be
um secondly can i welcome um
wholeheartedly the confirmation from the
prime minister that those people who are
off the gas grid will be protected by
this announcement a full 40 percent of
my constituents are off the gas grid and
i believe the number is broadly similar
in the prime minister's own constituency
um but a specific question it's great
that there's been confirmation they're
going to be helped but a bit more detail
on process is important for this reason
people who buy oil
and people that buy
lpg have to tend to buy in lumps they
have to fill a tank
and they will need to know if they for
example were to place an order today
to make sure they have sufficient energy
they will need to know whether the cost
of that order will be covered by this um
price guarantee or whether it will only
be for deliverers that take place after
the first of october so
even though the details may need to be
worked through some confirmation about
that i think is incredibly important it
would be terrible if someone on a low
income made a very expensive purchase
today
and then discovered they'd inadvertently
cut themselves out of help but equally
we don't want people running out of
energy by delaying those purchases the
final point is just to flesh out what i
said in my interventional leader of the
opposition my understanding is the 170
billion pounds excess profit over half
of that
includes profits made
by foreign companies on energy supplied
to the united kingdom that is not within
the scope
of the exchequer to be able to tax it
and secondly we already have a windfall
tax we're already taxing excess profits
at a total rate of 65 and that winful
tax has been legislated for by this
house and it will stretch forward to
december 2025.
so i don't really know what the labour
party are
arguing for and i notice in my
intervention the leader of the
opposition would not say at what rate he
thought a windfall tax should raise 65
seems quite high to me helpful if labour
could confirm what they believe it
should be
davey
speaker following the speaker's
statement earlier i think all our hearts
and thoughts and prayers are elsewhere
but i do want to contribute to the
debate and to
actually agree with the honourable
member for the forest of dean on his
questions on heating oil and that's a
critical issue for many many people in
rural communities and we do need answers
we need them
immediately
mr speaker what the prime minister has
just announced is not a freeze on
people's energy bills
in the middle of a costly emergency the
conservatives are choosing
to put energy bills up by another 500
pounds for struggling families
this hike in people's energy bills comes
on top of the 700 pound rise we saw
last april
struggling families were paying twice as
much for energy as they were last year
people will still be desperately worried
about how they're going to keep warm
this winter
last may's 400 pound discount
simply won't make up for this enormous
rise in energy bills
so where is the new support for families
and pensioners who are struggling
under the prime minister's plan mr
speaker fewer poverty will get worse
not better
and turning to the way we think she's
proposing to pay for this package
why does it seem the government is
handing an eye watering bill to
taxpayers
in the form of higher borrowing
which we all know ultimately means
higher taxes for
for taxpayers and particularly for our
children
this doesn't seem concerned it doesn't
seem
right
why has she rejected the alternative of
a windfall tax on today's oil and gas
giants who are raking in enormous
unexpectedly high profits
thanks to president putin's invasion of
ukraine
how is it fair mr deputy speaker
to take money from future taxpayers from
our children
and to hand it to today's oil and gas
barrens
how is it responsible
to borrow so much
to pay for consumption
when our economy is already in such a
mess
with the pound falling so dangerously
and on energy policy mr deputy speaker
the fair and response responsible policy
is to increase investment
massively
in the cheapest and most popular forms
of energy available to us wind and solar
i was
absolutely shocked that the prime
minister did not announce a massive
expansion a fast expansion of renewables
to bring people's energy bills down
mr speaker the prime minister has made
some alarming choices today
rejecting cheap wind and solar power
raising people's energy bills even
higher than they are now refusing extra
support for struggling families and
pensioners and paying for a policy with
higher taxes on our children instead of
a windfall tax on fossil fuels these are
the wrong choices
thank you mr deputy speaker and can i
start by saying may god bless our queen
i welcome today's announcement very
sincerely i think it's fantastic that
we've seized this massive problem facing
us and it will give huge relief to so
many households and businesses who have
quite frankly been terrified by the
prospect of what was to come and so
having that reassurance now will be
greatly uh pleasing to them i'm
convinced i did want to just take a
couple of minutes however to talk about
some really low hanging fruit
that i don't think we've made enough of
yet and with current energy prices where
they are there's a lot more that we
could do as a government
for example
by going house to house through energy
suppliers not as government officials
but to assist people with looking at how
they can reduce their own energy bills
and there are many many practical ways
not least of which some great ideas for
turning down the thermostat on your
boiler don't do this yourselves at home
but nevertheless um turning that down to
make more effective our use of energy
and secondly things like turning down
the hot pressure the hot water tap
pressure to actually reduce people's
energy bills these things are a really
low hanging fruit you could do tomorrow
and that some that that forecasters
suggest could save up to 10 of energy
bills but most importantly of all is
insulation and again current energy
prices are a game changer for insulation
and some research recently out suggests
that a thousand pounds could pay for the
basic um cavity wall or loft insulation
for the average household and that the
sector could insulate up to half a
million homes this winter and a million
homes next year and that actually would
in itself potentially be cost neutral to
the treasury because of course then the
treasury won't be paying the excess to
pay for the price cap so with energy
prices at these levels it is worth
looking again at massively ramping up um
insulation at household level and then
finally i won't give way because there's
so little time finally in terms of
businesses so many have said to me as
business secretary and then as chairman
of the backbench base committee so many
businesses say to me but we can't get a
grid connection for our solar panels so
there's no point doing it again i would
say to them with energy prices where
they are you can get yourselves a
battery you could actually have some
internal independence in energy and i
think many businesses should be looking
at that and the role of government
should be to provide advice through the
energy suppliers thank you
florence
thank you madam
and i just wanted to echo the comments
of my honorable friend from swansea east
with regard to dialysis patients my late
mum was a dialysis sufferer due to her
sickle cell and she dialyzed three times
a week and one one of the reasons she
didn't want to switch to home dialysis
was because of the costs so i know that
many sickle cell patients who have to
have their heating on this winter and
many dialysis patients will be worrying
so much about how they will pay their
bills
in terms of what the prime minister
announced earlier this
morning for my constituents in vauxhall
the next two years will be fraught with
so many difficulties without the right
actions from this government and the
decisions they have made today will
impact them for many years to come and i
hope that the prime minister and the new
government will have this in mind when
they make decisions over the next few
years madam deputy speaker solving the
energy crisis is the first test of this
new government are they going to make
big decisions on the oil and gas firms
that are making record profits why
people up and down this country continue
to suffer
are they going to be fiscally
responsible doing everything in their
power to ensure that it lowers the
burdens on future generations are they
going to support families who are
already making desperate ends between
putting food on the table or heating
their homes i'm afraid to say on the
basis of the announcements we've seen
this afternoon and what we've heard from
the government the answer is a
resounding no
for many of my constituents in voxel the
cost of living crisis did not start when
ofcom raised the price cap last month
for many of them it didn't even start
when russia invaded ukraine earlier this
year
the squeeze that they've been seeing in
their wages and not keeping up with the
prices have been the future of this
government over the last few years
households have been squeezed
relentlessly over decades and with
statistics from the trussell's trust
showing that over 20 000 food parcels
were distributed in lambert between
april 2019 and march 2020
the shock of the energy crisis has been
severe but we can't keep
ignoring the fact that a number of
households have been left in this
position as their bills continue to sky
high
we can't ignore the fact that the
failure to insulate homes
over failed insulation policies with the
end of the warm front discount
introduced by the label government
but what do we get from this government
we get the rule book ripped up on
fracking while people
continue to not see
untapped onshore wind potential we get
attack on workers rights people taken to
lose a day's pay or in some cases more
to fight for their wage increase and
their workers rights
we see scraps of policy on insulation on
our homes our as our homes continue to
bleed the energy they need bearing the
hallmark of the incompetence of the last
12 years of this conservative government
madam deputy speaker we can't afford to
go on like this enough is enough and we
need a sea change from this government
to recognize the issues that people in
vauxhall and up and down this country
say
are facing we need a sea change and we
need a new government
chris green
thank you madam deputy speaker um
i welcome the prime minister uh her
statement uh today uh setting up two
broad uh areas firstly the immediate
support she's gonna be giving so many
people right around the country and also
to businesses like many here perhaps all
here uh many constituents of mine been
getting in touch to say how concerned
they are
uh about the cost of energy now and how
fearful they are about the cost of
energy uh this coming winter so the
decisive action uh the prime minister
has taken is incredibly welcome
but i'd like also to highlight the
longer term vision that she uh she has
we know that much of the problems at the
moment are caused by the evasion of
ukraine by vladimir putin and the
russian army but we also look back to
the 1970s and the oil crisis so we can
see
if we are dependent upon
foreign sources of energy for our
heating our homes empowering our
industry we're always going to be in a
vulnerable place i welcome the prime
minister's ambition for the united
kingdom to have
britain become a next a net exporter of
energy by uh 2040. i think this is a
hugely positive ambition for united
kingdom for our industry and also for
the sector itself and i particularly
like to emphasize one aspect
of the energy sector i think nuclear
needs to form a key part of our energy
sector in the united kingdom it's that
reliable
base load energy we can depend upon come
rain or shine the northwest of england
whether in cheshire lancashire cumbria
the north west of england has a huge
talent
right across those three counties
in the sector and by investing in this
and giving us more security in the
sector we're going to be protecting and
securing those jobs and i'm just
thinking as well of springfield's near
preston
the nuclear
fuels plant there we need the security
for that plant to ensure it can maintain
itself and maintain its staff the
skilled engineers the skilled
apprenticeships apprentices uh in that
site we need to secure that site and
many other uh other places in the
northwest of england uh warrington and
the wider area i think as well has an
enormous wealth of talent happy to give
way remember i found the honorable
member for giving away um does the
honourable member share my concern about
one of the announcements around
fracking i'm quite confident my
community won't accept that and i know
certainly the honourable members
constituency of bolton west and those
beautiful war religions surrounding it
because they feel that they'll accept
that as well
the the prime minister is committed to
respecting the views and values of local
communities and i support that
but i'm trying to focus on nuclear
energy in my short period of time i have
to contribute and i think the other
aspect
both in the northwest we want that
commitment but also hinkley c uh that's
a phenomenal site uh for normal
investment
in our united kingdom
and i want to see our commitment to
nuclear energy and the phenomenal uh
workforce in that site in hinkley c in
somerset i want to see that workforce go
on to the next
nuclear project
and a whole series of nuclear projects
uh whether it's the full-scale nuclear
reactors or whether it's the smrs
so i think there's a huge potential i
think there's a huge ambition that the
prime minister
uh is going to set out and the business
secretary is going to give more details
on and this is immensely positive for so
many different parts of our country are
particularly welcome as well the
location of roswell's smr headquarters
in the city of manchester as well
order just before we move on absolutely
no problem with there being
interventions however i would advise
sticking to the three minutes because
obviously that not everybody is going to
necessarily get in so interventions do
mean that the speaker gets an extra
minute which means it's an extra minute
of somebody else so please take
interventions but i would really
appreciate it for if the colleagues then
stuck to the uh three minutes caroline
lucas thank you very much madam deputy
speaker and i echo the best wishes to
her majesty the new prime minister takes
up her role at a moment when the country
is facing a series of multiple crises of
staggering proportions including a
likely recession and let's not forget
the accelerating climate emergency which
in the words of the ipcc means that
there is and i say a brief and rapidly
closing window to secure a livable
future so this moment required bold
visionary thinking grounded in
compassion not cold and outdated
economic dogma it called for a retrofit
revolution a massive investment in a
home insulation and renewable energy
upgrades that could finally deliver warm
homes and lower bills i was staggered
that the prime minister didn't mention
once those demand-side measures that
need to be put into the into the
communities around our country so that
people can finally have lower bills and
warmer homes what it did not call for
were measures that would lock us into
further dependence on fossil fuels
because while putin's war in europe
ukraine has accelerated this crisis it
is fundamentally one caused by our
dependence on gas and it won't be solved
by extracting more gas and it certainly
won't be solved by a resumption of
fracking which would be a disaster for
the climate and a measure which as her
own chancellor admitted barely six
months ago would do nothing to lower
energy bills and would fail to produce
enough gas to meet even one percent of
our needs for more than the next three
years
coming to the detail of her support
package i welcome the fact that she has
finally acted on a price freeze but
these measures are nowhere near enough
they are poorly targeted and without a
substantial package of additional
support will fail to protect millions of
low-income families who are already in
free fall they can't cope with current
prices never mind an increase and that's
why my party would return the price cap
to its more affordable rate of last
october these measures do nothing to
incentivize a reduction in demand energy
demand for those who can do that and
most staggering of all as we've heard so
much they allow the oil and gas
companies to get off scot-free despite
the treasury's own documents showing
that energy producers are in line to
make 170 billion in excess profits over
the next two years
so what we need to do is to scrap the
shameful investment allowance put in a
winful tax that is proportionate to the
crisis that we face and make that the
first step towards a permanent carbon
tax on oil and gas companies to reach at
the very least the global average of 70
percent that would bring the uk in line
with countries such as angola and
trinidad i want to say i welcome the
fact that the government has been
consulting on decoupling the price of
renewables from gas that would be a game
changing step but i also want to ask her
to do a massive investment in renewable
energy renewables are a staggering nine
times cheaper than gas there are 650
wind and solar projects oven ready and
waiting that is the way forward not
putting us more into more and more
fossil fuels and finally will the
government look at measures like a
rising block tariff approach which will
be much fairer into the future
stephen crabbe thank you madam deputy
speaker and well the thoughts of the
house of first and foremost with her
majesty the queen this afternoon i do
think it's important that we take the
opportunity to debate these challenges
today i i welcome the speed with which
the government has moved
to bring forward a very strong package
of measures that have been announced
today i welcome the substance of that
package i think it provides a very
strong platform to help get families
through this immediate price crisis for
me it meets the test of scale
it meets the test of timeliness and it
provides certainty for those families
who've been living in a state of frankly
anxiety thinking about the enormous
bills that have been coming their way i
welcome the assurance from the prime
minister today that this package will
cover everybody so there won't be gaps
it will cover the more than 50 percent
of households in my constituency who who
have homes are off the grass grid and
rely on heating oil and lpg i also want
to make sure that people who live in
park homes are able to access the
support that they need and there
shouldn't be gaps
i still think madam deputy speaker there
would be further measures that we'll we
will need to take to strengthen some of
the social protection for those on the
very lowest incomes despite the measures
that have been announced today i think
there are some easy wins for the
government around freezing or limiting
the deductions that we take from
people's social security payments i
think we should look again at the
benefit cap and i think most importantly
it would be good for this new
administration to reiterate the
commitment of the last government to
do a full social security up rating in
the new year i think it's important
madam deputy speaker that the the
measures also cover businesses i've
heard from so many small businesses in
my constituency during the summer
particularly the food manufacturers
breweries so many hospitality and
tourism businesses who for them frankly
this is an existential issue these are
good businesses but if prices go the way
that uh are being predicted frankly
thousands of companies good companies up
and down the country and all of our
constituencies will be put out of
business
and finally madam deputy speaker on the
measures announced today around strategy
for
improving uk energy supply i do strongly
welcome these a number of members have
raised different energy sources they
want to see more movement on i would
just flag up madam deputy speaker the
enormous opportunity that's opening up
in the celtic sea with floating offshore
wind i think this is a really good
timely moment for the government working
with the crown estate to accelerate
progress on these pro projects but none
of that is an immediate answer none of
these new nuclear power stations that
some members want to see in terms of the
immediate levers available to government
for this winter and a potential energy
supply crisis there aren't many madame
deputy speaker and we are looking at gas
supply and i would really encourage the
government to really sharpen its
strategy around procurement of more lng
cargos making sure that we do can
guarantee that we get the the energy
coming into our system to keep the
lights on this winter
lloyd russell thank you and mr speaker
um some of the announcements are welcome
particularly a focus on people who are
not on the grid
i would like to highlight to the front
bench and i do hope that they will go
away and seek more clarity for people
who
resell
energy often landlords in blocks who buy
the energy on the commercial market and
resell it to their tenants it's never
been explicitly mentioned by the
government they've talked about heat
networks which is if the landlord is
running a boiler directly to that flat
those meters are not on the official
meter grid they will not be eligible for
the 400 pound support from this
government even at the moment unless
action is taken there needs to be some
urgent action there to ensure that the
landlords can purchase the prices at
fair prices and they pass them on at the
moment the landlord has to pass it on at
the purchase price i'm not saying
landlords are gouging but there is a
problem the purchase price is a
commercial price not a residential price
so i do hope that they will come back
with further clarity on that but the
reality is that this package still is a
500 pound increase on what energy bills
are today this is not a reduction this
is an increase and it didn't need to be
like this it didn't need to be like this
because we could have
regulated the wholesale market price and
the government could have stepped in and
offered loans to energy companies to
bridge the gap for the gas that they are
importing that could have been the offer
where the debt was put on the energy
companies not on the state but that
wasn't what has been put forward today
we could have seen
the government fixing energy prices at
what they are today and making
interventions but they didn't see that
either and so there are some real
difficulties with this about who pays is
it the profits of the companies or is it
the backs of the people and i'm afraid
the wrong choice has been made because
future generations and even this
generation in future years will be
paying for this and that does not seem
right to me and of course there were
some slight mentions around improvements
of efficiencies but not enough we need
as my honourable friend has been calling
for actually in my neighbor a house to
house street by street approach for
installation and for getting this right
it does not work letting it down to the
market you do not get the efficiencies
of scale labor has put forward a plan to
start that but it needs even more
ambition
and we need to also be looking at the
production of wind onshore not just
offshore onshore and solar panels on our
roofs at the moment the solar panel
feeding tamif is less than the cost of
buying energy directly from the market
that does not work we need to reverse
that the incentive needs to be
that people are paying into the grid at
a fair market price that they are paying
out
claire cutino thank you
speaker
all summer like many of you in this
house
i've been hearing from households
businesses schools and other public
sector organizations community centres
who've been worried about their energy
bills going up five-fold in many cases
so i warmly welcome both the speed of
this package and this ambition of this
package which i think will bring much
certainty to businesses and peace of
mind to households and others i also
welcome that we were very clear i think
about the the discretionary funding that
will be provided for users of heating
all of which i've got many people in my
constituency
and also the reform of the electricity
pricing market so not non-gas power
producers uh are more fairly priced
therefore uh lowering the cost for many
users as well
and the clarity which i think has been
provided for those who are switching
contracts and will not face exit
penalties i think will again
be very positive
for many
instinctively i would prefer a targeted
support program
however i will say from the work that
i've been doing for the last
12 months or longer in the treasury
looking at costs of living there are
challenges with that approach in that we
know where all the people are who use
energy we know where all the people are
who are on benefits but we don't know
much about those middle income people we
did try through a council tax band
approach to target a bit more but it's
imperfect so i think actually the
universal approach they've adopted here
is the right one
because we cannot we cannot let middle
income households go to the wall and the
truth is when you have energy prices
going up by so much there are many
people who are outside of the benefit
system who may be on thirty thousand
forty thousand pounds would be hugely
struggling right now without this
program
however we cannot deny that there are
problems when you distort price signals
through price controls and therefore i
was very pleased to hear the prime
minister talk about energy efficiency
and energy security and supply which
would be critical if we get through this
period
and lastly i just wanted to come back on
this windfall tax point that's been
mentioned multiple times by the
opposition the 170 billion pounds which
they know those profits are not being
made here and not taxable and the reason
i know they know that is they set out
their own plans a week ago and actually
they only wanted to recoup eight billion
pounds from the oil and gas companies so
if they really truly thought there was
170 billion pounds up for grabs we know
how much they love grabbing profits why
did they not set out 20 30 50 even 100
billion pounds it's because they know
that's not possible and actually we did
put forward an increase in their taxes
and oil and gas companies are paying not
the 19 corporation tax that other
companies are paying not even the 40
that they pay normally but 65 percent
two-thirds of their profits are coming
into the tax system and as much as
possible that they can invest the rest
of it that's what we will need for
long-term solutions to protect our
households our businesses our schools
our charities and more
hey there's several robots
i too would like to send my best wishes
to her majesty the queen
today's announcement shows beyond doubt
whose side the new prime minister is on
he's prepared to force taxpayers to
carry the burden of borrowing billions
of pounds in order to subsidize the
shareholders of energy companies who are
profiting from putin's war
and it's shocking she can't even tell us
how much that burden is going to cost
today
i must urge her to think again make
energy companies pay their fair share
the global energy norm of energy profit
taxation is 70 percent norway stands at
78 percent why does the population of
the uk have to suffer the combined yokes
of higher taxes worse public services
and falling real wages while private
profit profit is protected under her
premiership
use that money to return the energy
price cap to the pre-april level of
1277 pounds per year and extend that cap
to small businesses and charities people
are struggling now even at current
prices 180 000 households in wales are
forced to are forced to struggle even to
afford items such as heating food and
toiletries bills of 2500 pounds are
unaffordable for many many people
anything short of 1277 pounds as a cap
will fail to meet the scale of the
crisis we face
and it will require her government and
this is important to bring forward
additional packages of support for
vulnerable households including doubling
the 650 pound cost of living payment and
revising the legit eligibility criteria
to include those on disability benefits
who are currently excluded from support
this will cost us more in future if we
don't face what is facing what is
genuinely facing us now but of course
what we're calling on her here is
instead of pursuing fantasy economics of
rampant deregulation and tax cuts for
the rich the prime minister must also
prioritize reduction in energy demand
and investment in low carbon sources
that's the only way to bring down energy
bills in the medium and long term
finally and to be clear and simple on
this it is time to unchain wales's
renewable and low carbon energy
potential by
vastly improving our grid capacity
bringing forward smrs at transformers in
my constituency and willva and other
places as well
empowering welsh government to deliver
large-scale transformative
infrastructure projects such as tidal
lagoons devolving management of the
crown estate to wales and enabling
community energy schemes to realize
their full potential by selling their
power directly to local customers
for us in wales it is now clear that in
the long term
to fix this crisis for good we must
place our energy system and its huge
potential in the hands of the people of
wales for the benefit of the people of
wales
dean russell
madame deputy speaker and given the
announcement early may i also send my
best wishes to her majesty the queen um
from myself and also from all those
across watford
the announcement today i felt was a very
important one over the summer i spent
lots of time volunteering with
organizations including the citizens
advice bureau through to working in the
british heart foundation shop and i
heard firsthand uh the challenges that
people are feeling around the fears that
they have around the um
the the fuel crisis and their bills and
what we heard today was a significant
package which will help people
immediately but also deal with the
long-term challenges that we face whilst
also making sure economically that it
does work because as we all know
windfall taxes are a one-off
potentially a two-off if you could call
it that but once you get to the third or
fourth try it's not going to work and so
what we need is something that works
immediately long term but also puts us
on a competitive footing around the
world and what we did here today which i
thought was a really important point was
about the fact that in by 2040 we want
to be a net energy exporter and what
does that mean it means many things it
doesn't just mean the important part
about our own fuel security but it
actually means investment in jobs
investment in education investment in
skills investment in business to make
sure that we're looking ahead not to be
not only in this situation again because
we do not want to be in this situation
again but also to help other countries
around the world not be in this this
position again because of the fact that
we are actually looking long-term
one final point i want to make so i'm
conscious you'd like short speeches and
uh if anything i am short um i i i i
would just say this that's i think very
important i i studied physics at
university i'm probably one of the few
mps that studied nuclear physics as part
of my my course not that i was that
great at it but i think the talk of
nuclear um moving forward is so
important we have had a negative image
of nuclear over many many decades and
the opportunity to small modular nuclear
reactors uh that go across this country
that enable us to have
safe green energy that entire
communities can rely upon us is
absolutely essential but also i think
there's an infrastructure of skills and
education that go into that so i would
just say i massively welcome this
package i think it's the right package
there's more to do of course as always
but i welcome the debate today and i
think let's be certain on one thing that
we need to say to all of our residents
who are at the moment fearful of what
may come that this will support them in
the short term people may disagree about
what the long-term approach is i think
this will support them now we'll support
them in winter and they should feel
reassured that they're going to be okay
thank you madam deputy speaker
great davis
the speaker um when people talk about
famines they think about food shortages
but what famines are in fact is a
combination of higher prices alongside
lower wages and we are approaching
famine conditions in britain because
after 12 years of uk austerity with cuts
and services frozen wages devaluation of
the pound our people are much weaker
facing this tsunami of price rises we've
seen from putin's a brutal war and the
response we've seen from
the oil companies of course is that
their operating costs are just the same
that the prices go up they make windfall
profits that they have picked the
pockets of british people and we demand
our money back there is a a sort of
windfall tax at the moment
we that should be continued at
international rates has been said so we
don't face a situation where there's yet
another increase of another 500 pounds
on people's household budgets
millions of people are in desperate
poverty and simply can't afford that um
the prime minister rightly talks about
growth what she needs to remember is
that the oecd have found that growth is
is less if there's greater inequality
yet at the same time she's talking about
giving back national insurance where the
the bottom 10 percent will get an extra
7 pounds 60. the top 10 percent will get
1 800 pounds so in other words she will
be increasing inequality through putting
more burdens onto households giving the
rich more in tax giveaways including
national insurance and not taxing the
excess and unjustified profits of big
corporations the oecd also found that
growth was very much linked to the
education of the poorest and the
ambition of the government is simply to
get education spending up to 2010 levels
by 2024 but they won't even achieve that
because of inflation uh coretta king
famously said that poverty is a child
without an education and we've seen
education standards now fall through the
pandemic in particular for the poorest
so we need to invest there meanwhile
we've got a situation where the
government's provoking a trade war with
the eu over the protocol bank of england
rates are likely to go up they're
provoking strikes with the trade union
movement but what we want is growth and
what we saw with a labor party in the
10th year to 2008 was 40 percent growth
in the economy that allowed us to invest
double investment education and in
health and had trend growth continued
from the labor government the average
income in britain would be 10 000 pounds
more so they'd be more resilient to
these external shocks of um
of the pandemic and the energy crisis so
we need to think about that and we need
to invest in very much in hydrogen
instead of fracking and invest in
renewables instead of more and more oil
or order richard graham
madame deputy speaker i joined with all
colleagues here and not here in sending
the warmest wishes of support from
everyone in gloucester her majesty the
queen and members of the royal family
today's announcement made within 48
hours of the new government being formed
no small achievement will bring huge
certainty and reassurance to
residents in my constituency and
elsewhere and also to those living in
park homes in charities and across the
public sector as well
as small businesses in particular who
are already suffering
and this is absolutely critical because
it does put a cap on the maximum average
energy bill and i do think mad index
speaker the crucial word is maximum
because as the right honourable member
for south northamptonshire said earlier
there are huge advantages to a program
of advice and best practice being led by
the government in helping us all to
reduce our energy consumption schools
for example could hugely benefit from
solar panels that could sell all the
energy generated during the long summer
holidays into the grid and thereby
bringing down their annual bills
considerably so there are lots of good
things to welcome in today's
announcement
but there are three things in particular
i would like to raise with the ministers
on the front bench
firstly the green levees that are now
going to be temporarily suspended have
of course already been committed
elsewhere so who is going to pay for
them now presumably the taxpayer in
general
secondly
the
nic the national insurance contribution
increase was predicted to raise 36
billion over three years for health and
care budgets so how is that now going to
be delivered because the
task before our new health secretary
is big on generating better outcomes but
reducing the inputs will surely make
that harder
thirdly then the contribution of energy
companies we've heard a lot today and
quite rightly about how they are already
paying some 66 tax in real terms but
nonetheless there is a huge difference
between profits which are good and war
profiteering which is bad and i do think
the new secretary of state could shed
light on how the energy companies are
going to contribute to this national
challenge
lastly then on fracking the honourable
member for vauxhall said that the rules
were going to be completely ripped up
the rules on fracking i don't think that
is the case because the crucial barrier
is that of local support which has been
conspicuously absent so far so i doubt
we will see any real change
in practice and there is one last thing
madame deputy speaker to add a lot has
been said about the welcome commitment
by this government to nuclear and
renewables quote embracing diverse
sources of energy unquote and can i just
encourage the new secretary of state to
follow the great example of his
predecessor in supporting marine energy
stephen flynn
thank you madam speaker i paid
particular attention to the very very
small note which came out from the
secretary of state for business energy
and industrial strategy earlier and the
particular line that says this will save
the typical household one thousand
pounds a year one thousand pounds a year
madam deputy speaker it's almost like
the cap which is being put in place at
two and a half thousand pounds a year
isn't double what energy prices were
just last
summer it's almost as if the government
doesn't understand the sheer scale of
the financial problems facing households
right across the country because of
course it's not just about energy prices
inflation is at a 40-year high interest
rates are at a 30-year
high wages are at a 20-year low and yet
we're being told we should be happy
about energy bills being frozen at two
and a half
thousand pounds
per year it's absurd it's not just
households are going to be struggling
it's obviously going to be businesses as
well we've heard a number of businesses
spoken about in the chamber here today
and i think i've spent most of the
summer having emails from businesses who
are being utterly utterly crippled by
the costs
that are in front of them and up till
now the government hasn't even lifted a
finger and what they are proposing will
not go far enough businesses will
continue to close because of energy
prices
and this whole debate
really frustrates me for a particular
reason
because i happen to represent a
constituency which is famed for oil and
gas production
somewhat ironically of course it was the
unionist parties within this chamber who
told us in 2014 the oil and gas was
running out and yet now they're telling
us there's going to be an addition of a
hundred new licences given but baron
barry not irony isn't not absurd
energy-rich scotland which produces six
times
more gas than we produce is even having
to face
an energy price crisis when it comes to
electricity gas makes up just
14.4 per cent of our electricity
production yet the price of that gas
dictates all
the fact that the vast majority of our
electricity comes from low carbon
sources means absolutely nothing the
fact that it comes primarily from
renewables means absolutely nothing when
it comes to the costs that are being
imposed upon the people of scotland by
this
uk government and the failure the
continued failure of their energy policy
so if the uk government want to do just
one thing
as a suggestion to the new secretary of
state will this government finally
decouple renewables from gas prices that
would make a huge difference and of
course it wouldn't cost a single penny
here
jamery miller thank you madam deputy
speaker and following the speaker's
earlier announcement can i join others
by passing my warmest uh wishes on
behalf of the people of basingstoke to
her majesty the queen and her family
but can i also
very warmly welcome the rapid action the
government and the prime minister has
taken
since the formation of the new
government earlier this week
not only the short-term uh
support that's been announced today but
also the the focus on the long-term uh
solutions to the problems that we're
facing clearly the energy price
guarantee will provide an enormous
amount of certainty um and reassurance
to many many families including those
who've contacted me over the summer
months
and i think perhaps uh the government
will want to take some time to ensure
that there's clarity uh just just
following on from some of the
contributions today about how the new
energy price guarantee will sit
alongside the existing energy bill
support scheme which will already
provide
a great deal of support to many of the
vulnerable groups who honourable members
across the house have referred to today
because it's both of those schemes which
are going to make sure
that people get the support and
certainty they need at these difficult
times i was particularly pleased to hear
madam deputy speaker
following
some representations i've had from
people who live in park homes and who
are also on on heatmen networks and have
and as many of my constituents do use
heating oil um that particular support
will be in place there but can i echo
the comments of the honourable member
for my writing my friend the member for
forrest of dean it would be useful to
know exactly how that support will come
into play i was also extremely pleased
to hear um from the prime minister
the support for businesses uh charities
and public services that will be
equivalent to the support for
residential properties for six months um
can i uh again uh suggest that
understanding quickly how that might
work in practice will be helpful
particularly for charities who will be
planning ahead up to 12 months ahead on
how their operations will work
many of those charities of course are
community centres village halls who run
child care facilities essential to our
residents
and then finally madame deputy speaker
could i take this opportunity of
broadening the debate by encouraging the
government to look at those industries
who've been hit by the increase in gas
prices and here i'm particularly talking
about the fertilizer industry i met
farmers in my own constituency on friday
and as madame deputy speaker all know
gas is used to create fertilizer and
that's why it's relevant to this debate
and that scaling back of production
throughout europe is leaving many
farmers particularly my constituency
sowing seed for harvests next year
without knowing that that fertilizer is
going to be in place so maybe the
government can make an early statement
um on how we're going to make sure
surety is supply of fertilizers given
the impact of gas prices on their
production we are in a difficult
situation i'm pleased the government has
made such a speedy order
and just to point out that if um
colleagues were less than three minutes
we get more people in
thank you deputy speaker we must not
forget that for months this tory
government saw the oncoming tidal wave
of rising energy bills this winter yet
chose to do nothing about it for monster
callously and deliberately left people
in limbo creating
only imaginable uncertainty for people
who faced colossal energy bills this
christmas
and for months they let fear spread
amongst those preparing to make a
desperate choice between heating their
home or putting food on their table yet
what is worse
is that for months the current prime
minister who was a minister
in this government for a decade was
content to go along with this grossly
negligent plan of inaction wasting
valuable time when we could have been
protecting people
and as we heard the prime minister today
on that dispatch box
she used the word immediate she used the
word
urgent support on a number of occasions
well frankly that's disingenuous because
the prime minister cannot suddenly
pretend that she's entered parliament
today she has been a senior minister in
previous governments for the last decade
and frankly speaking she could have
taken action along with the previous
government months ago and not put put
people through this uncertainty madame
dr speaker addressing a number of other
uh smoke and mirrors as is customary
from the party opposite firstly
we've heard the reference to price price
freeze on a number of occasions well
that's simply not true the point that
has been made by other speakers is
what we are seeing is a price rise of at
least 500 pounds from what people are
currently paying and hundreds more from
what people were originally paying
hundreds of pounds more than my
constituents can afford to pay and madam
deputy speaker
we also have heard
silence today silence
from the prime minister on who actually
will pay for it what is absolutely clear
and the prime minister has made this uh
spell this out christopher is the people
that will not pay for it is the
corporate oil and gas
barons that have made 170 billion pound
profit and in this her what first week
as prime minister
she has made it absolutely clear that
her direction of travel is to continue
to drive a wedge between those that
continue to get wealthier in this
country and those that continue to
suffer poverty and that she will always
side on the big corporates as opposed to
ordinary working people thank you
okay
can i also send my deepest thoughts and
good wishes to her majesty the queen and
her family as i'm sure
the people of dudley north would want to
send as well
we know madam deputy speaker that too
many people have borne the brunt of
covid uh in recent times and now too
many people are there in the cost of
living crisis which we now find
ourselves in
some of them ask me marco
what are you doing to help us
i'm going to have to choose whether to
turn on my hot water or feed my children
when it comes to local businesses a
local owner has contacted me
this week saying they are having extreme
difficulties with energy prices so much
so
that they feel they have no choice
but to streamline staff in order to
continue trading
and paying their bills
no one ever should really find
themselves in a position where they have
to make these kinds of choices whether a
business or a household
ordinary hardworking people
should not be suffering with anxiety
about how they will make ends meet this
winter
i
like our new prime minister want to
ensure that my constituents and indeed
all of our constituents get the support
they need and we have the certainty for
the months ahead and so therefore i'm
pleased that she's taking this action
immediately to provide support and peace
of mind
for so many
madam deputy speaker the words i would
like to use to describe
vladimir putin are not appropriate for
the polite company of this house
but it is because of him
we sit in this house having this very
debate
now of course kobit did play a large
part in the cost of living crisis but it
is putin's bully boy tactics cutting off
europe's energy supply plunging us
into the freezing waters that we are
facing
putin did not care if jenny in gornall
can feed her children get them to school
putin does not care if dorothy incedely
can heed her home in her old age putin
does not care if john in dudley has to
close his business and lay off all his
staff because he can't pay his energy
bill and continue to employ them
fusion just does not care
but i do and i know all of us here do
winter is coming and we know what could
come with it but it does not need to be
an inevitability and now thanks to our
new prime minister it will not be
the long-term plan to strengthen and
secure britain's energy suppliers and to
re-open up
the north sea and open up fracking
and
investing in nuclear will ensure our
children and grandchildren do not face
these issues as they reach our grand old
ages
the new support being pledged today goes
a long way to reassure individuals
families and our local businesses our
new prime minister is on our side not
just in the short term but in the long
term cooper
you met him deputy speaker earlier this
week i raised the plight of households
sorry
it's okay
sorry
um thank you my own deputy speaker
earlier this week i raised the plight of
households small businesses and care
homes in my constituency and i'm sure
like me many of them will be truly
shocked that it is the british public
that will have to bear the burden of
paying for this energy crisis whilst
energy companies continue to make their
millions but today i have a number of
very specific questions that i'd like to
put to ministers on the front bench and
i would ask whether they might address
them in their summing up first of all
the written statement talks about an
equivalent guarantee for businesses but
does that include care homes
specifically and what additional support
will be given to care homes given the
pressure that they are under
women's street safety i've had an email
from my county council hertfordshire
county council saying that the bill to
keep street lights on has increased by
60 percent in just a few short months
and it already now costs an extra 2.3
million pounds a year to keep the lights
on after it goes dark they are not yet
talking about turning the lights off but
if they do are there contingency
measures in place to ensure that we keep
crime down the people are safe
particularly women on our streets after
dark
on park homes i welcome the fact that
there is a fund for park homes to cover
people with heating oil and heat
networks but how will this fund work how
big will it be and will there be an
information campaign to those people who
can benefit from it the government's own
estimates suggest that one in every 100
households are impacted by having this
non-conventional relationship now by my
calculations that's more than a quarter
of a million properties so for each of
them to receive 400 pounds that would
need to be at least 100 million pounds
in that fund and madam deputy speaker we
need to have a revolution in renewables
res in is the world's largest
independent renewable company it's based
in my constituency of saint albans and
it has more than 40 years experience and
expertise
rsc tells me and friends of the earth
agree that footnote 54 of the national
planning policy framework stops them
from installing new onshore wind farms
even in areas where there are no
objections from local residents now i am
absolutely no fan of fracking but it is
obscene and absurd that this government
is saying that it's okay to reopen
fracking where communities are okay with
it but you're not going to be open
onshore wind where communities are okay
with it so please please review that
footnote and finally on solar panels uh
in january of this year i asked the
housing secretary if they may have a
requirement to make all new suitable
buildings have solar panels the
government has not conducted that
assessment of how big the roof space is
that's available but i would urge bays
to go further than looking at the floor
space that's available and look at the
set of these
non-domestic buildings and work out
precisely how much roof space is
available right now for having solar
panels installed thank you
virginia crosby but let me emphasize
again if everybody was two minutes we'd
have a much better chance of everybody
getting in i'm deputy speaker may i to
share my thoughts and prayers for our
queen and her family the energy crisis
has hit rural communities like mine on
honest mourn particularly badly on
honest morn schools shops and employment
are often too far away for walking and
public transport is sparse a car is not
a luxury it is a necessity and our
farming community relies on vehicles and
fuel driven equipment meaning that their
cost of production has risen
significantly we have a larger than
average elderly population who need to
stay warm in our sometimes harsh winters
and many of my constituents are reliant
on lpg and gas to fuel their homes and
this is common in rural communities but
there's often little local competition
and with no price cap in place families
are vulnerable to steeply rising costs
and i'm pleased that this is in an area
that is being addressed
my honor small constituents need help
and they need help today over the coming
months to heat and power their homes and
businesses and our prime minister has
now outlined her plans and this support
on top of the 37 billion already
committed by the formula chancellor
means that i'm hugely proud of what
we're doing to help with the immediate
problem but we need to do more to
protect the uk from these crisis in the
future and i know that our prime
minister has not lost sight of the
longer term whilst providing such
support in the short term and i welcome
her enthusiasm for nuclear she's already
spoken about the need to take back
control of our energy security invest
now in large-scale energy production and
incentivize communities to support
energy production in their area
the people of anna small which is also
known as energy island already welcome
this production locally we've got
companies like morlice and monesto have
received government backing to set up
tidal energy systems off our shores
we're home to stretches of onshore wind
and solar farms thanks to government
subsidies and support we have wilva once
a flagship of british nuclear power with
all the potential to reclaim that
position following this government's
commitment in the british energy
security strategy and the new nuclear
financing act and the holly head
hydrogen hub received 4.8 million of
funding in last year's budget
with companies like bechtel and
rolls-royce keen to re-establish nuclear
production at wilbur and bp mona looking
to earn a small to support large wind
farms in the irish sea my constituency
can be at the forefront of uk power
generation for decades to come a new
large-scale nuclear plant at wilbur and
anglesey could generate enough power for
every home in wales and more and small
module reactors could provide cheap
energy to local family and businesses in
shorter time scales on behalf of my
honor small constituents important that
this government takes into account the
unique energy demands on rural
communities short-term energy support
plans and that we grasp the benefits of
incentivizing communities to welcome
local energy production so that we can
secure our long-term domestic energy
supply swiftly
bergen thank you mr speaker six months
ago households faced energy bills of 1
300 pounds today we're told that
doubling that and fixing prices at 2 500
pounds is the best we can do to help
it's not people were struggling last
winter with their energy bills and many
more will be struggling this winter too
with prices doubled private energy
profits are being put before the needs
of people all whilst energy firms are
set to make 170 billion pounds in excess
profits this is a huge transfer of
wealth with big corporations
hoovering up even more of the wealth in
society paid for by millions of ordinary
people but the new prime minister and
former shell employee has been frank
energy firms in her view should be able
to keep those undeserved excess profits
a different principle should guide us
these companies should not be allowed to
make a single penny in excess profits
from this crisis that will require a
package of measures from public
ownership to full windfall taxes to caps
on the prices that north sea oil and gas
can be sold at all guided by the
principle the energy should be run for
the public good the public supports
those policies there are growing
movements for them this debate is not
going away today has not sold this
crisis today's limit on energy prices is
not a limit on the profits of north sea
oil and gas companies without the
windfall tax today
is about protecting their profits at
great social cost the claim that we need
to do this to guarantee the investment
by north sea oil and gas firms is
completely bogus because were investing
when they were making their normal
profits just a few months ago they were
never expecting this windfall and taxes
on oil and gas companies including in
norway's north sea fields are much
higher than here even at current
windfall tax rates energy security can't
be achieved by making ourselves more
dependent on the expensive fossil fuels
that have driven this crisis we don't
need more north sea explorations we
don't need fracking let's be clear this
gas won't be cheaper it will be sold at
world prices and anyway gas is nine
times more expensive than renewables
retrofitting would save people money and
reduce our gas use so this greater
reliance on fossil fuels is quite simply
ideological this government is using
this crisis to undermine its own
inadequate climate responsibilities the
profits of fossil fuel companies are
being put before the people and before
planets this approach is quite simply
failing people today hit by higher bills
and i'm afraid it will also fail future
generations hit by climate catastrophe
mike wood
mr speaker uh the the speed and the
scale of the support announced by the
prime minister is hugely welcomed and
it's obviously hugely necessary uh for
the many households you simply could not
have afforded energy bills of three and
a half thousand pounds it will make a
real
difference
uh together with the 400 pound payments
to each household the 650 pounds uh to
to those on low incomes and the 300
pounds go to pensioner our household i
hope that we can have some clarification
on what is the position of those
residential
properties that are on commercial meters
perhaps because they were converted from
previous uh commercial businesses it'll
also make a real difference to many
businesses whether that's in energy
intense businesses like ceramics and
glassmaking in my constituency whether
it's
hospital whether it's in hospitality but
similarly perhaps we can have further
clarification on what is the position
for those businesses who've had to
recently enter into
new contracts will they still be able to
switch uh to uh to the
new price cap or the new support that is
being
announced
in terms of the
criticisms that have been made
uh when full tax i mean that
there is some political
uh some superficial political uh
attraction to extending winfield texting
cause we do already have a windfall tax
set at 25 percent on top of the 40
texts already paid by british oil and
gas
producers
but i think the attraction is more
political and more superficial than it
is
real and
effective
in that the revenue that an extension
would raise would be very very small
compared to the scale of the cost of the
support that is uh that is necessary it
would affect less than half of the oil
and
gas that we use in the uk because less
than half is produced
in the uk
and by making
uk oil and gas production less
competitive
it will uh in the medium and the long
term reduce our energy security at the
worst possible time this is something we
can't afford it's also being suggested
it will uh affect price signals now as a
reformed economist i i know that
economists can sometimes dwell a bit too
much on good theory
and ignore the real world but i find it
hard to credit that people's behavior is
different if the price cap is two and a
half thousand pounds that they're more
careful with their energy than they
would have been at the extra thousand
pounds clearly if energy was free there
would be huge because but i think we're
ready at a level where people are being
very careful with what they use this
package is the right package it's an
effective package we need to get it into
uh household and businesses uh pockets
so that
castle
speaker uh whilst any help is welcome
this is in
insufficient by far for the poor and
generous and extreme for the rich
energy rich the perversity of an energy
rich scotland and fuel poor scotch
remains and what's clear is that not
only will people go cold this winter but
some may well die
there should have been april freeze it
should have been funded by a windfall
tax there should have been action on vat
and there are other emissions that
haven't been addressed or where clarity
remains changing the dysfunctional
energy market not just in
accelerating nuclear or fracking and
addressing the iniquities that still
exist and haven't been touched or at
least made clear first of all there's
prepayment meters the injustice remains
that the poorest those most deprived
those often most dependent upon the need
for power and energy
see themselves paying higher standing
charges and higher tariffs that hasn't
been touched well support has been given
to the very wealthy that must end it's
easily done a direction to off gem and
we all know that the energy companies
are capable of delivering it similarly
unregulated fuels whilst there's a
welcome announcement that some action
has been taken if it's simply to be a
discretionary fund then that is
inadequate it is especially the case in
the north of scotland but it's also the
situation in my own constituency that
people are off the gas grid they're
dependent upon heating oil biomass or
other fuels they shouldn't just be
available for some fund they may be able
to dip into they should be regulated the
secretary should be ensuring that that
is done and action should be taken
because those and often the most
climatically cold areas are the ones
that are going to be suffering and the
dysfunctional system remains we have
seen our electricity system tied to the
price of gas
97
of scotland's domestic electricity
supply is provided by renewables and yet
we are paying high sky-high prices
dependent upon foreign gas prices as
opposed to renewables that are on our
doorstep and over which we have a
surface
that is perverse especially when as you
said by others scotland is
self-sufficient in gas
this simply rewards the rich
it doesn't address the problems of the
poor it is inadequate
enough is enough and this is not enough
to end the crisis nor is it enough to
end the action that will be taken by
people
lord trout thank you madam deputy
speaker and my thoughts and prayers
along with everyone in seven oaks and
swanley are with her majesty the queen
and the royal family at this time
but uh turning the announcement today i
i warmly welcome it it will relieve a
huge amount of anxiety for my
constituents for businesses such as
donating manner who worried about being
crippled by prices and for schools such
as dunton green whose uh energy bills
were going up by 500
um i'm glad that uh we have heating oil
and heat networks included in this
although i will question as to whether
the prices will be frozen for them
because obviously they've gone up
extensively this year already tripled in
some cases uh boucher called for example
the heat network so it'd be helpful to
have clarification as to whether that
price would be frozen for them or be
allowed to go up and then we will um
we'll compensate them later um but i
wanted to add in an additional idea
which i've spoken about in this house
previously
with water supply it is illegal to cut
off water supply to a household
um you can recoup the cost of your water
company by going through the courts but
you cannot cut off supply for reasons of
non-payment
and i think this is something that we
should look at extending to energy
supply
because there are some protections in
place you're not allowed as an energy
company to cut a supply during the
winter months if a person lives on their
own uh if there's
someone today pension agent there or if
there's a child in the house
however you um
there is not enough protection in my
view and uh off gem showed that one in
seven households on a pre-payment meter
disconnected in 2019.
this is something that i think we should
look at seriously you know we cannot
have that number of disconnections which
are only likely to go up uh when
actually there's something that we can
do that will send a very clear
message to energy suppliers that they
get to and to consumers that they will
be safe this winter they do not need to
worry about um if they it really comes
to it their energy supplies will not be
cut off there will still be that
mechanism by which costs could be
recouped um but it will mean that
there is a safety net in place for
everybody
uh and i think that will go a huge a
huge way to providing reassurance for
people but i i welcome the announcement
today i think that it will um really
help my constituents uh and i hope to
see uh further further effort and work
been put in place in terms of ensuring
our energy supplies to households
deputy speaker well i too uh send my
best wishes to her majesty and her
family uh now we all recognize the need
to help people with fuel bills and there
is huge support amongst the public for a
further windfall tax on the oil and gas
companies as the companies have
explained themselves they'll still have
plenty of money for future investment
even after they've paid an additional
windfall tax the point is that the money
is there now on the table for the
government to use on behalf of the
people of the uk to pay for help with
fuel bills but under the government's
plans however it's worked out the point
is that it will be paid for by taxpayers
it is utterly disgraceful that the
government is not imposing a windfall
tax to cover these energy costs now i do
welcome the mentioned by the prime
minister of those who are off grid and
rely on heating oil and those who live
in homes with arrangements like park
homes or popular courting cross hands
where they do not have a bill directly
from an energy company but all these
households need to know as soon as
possible how and when they will receive
support and exactly how much it will be
the government's got an appalling record
on home installation energy efficiency
renewables and the transition away from
fossil fuels on insulation we've
repeatedly called for massive investment
programme to insulate nine million homes
two million of which could already have
been done by this winter investment in
renewables one of lefty speaker is vital
in tackling climate change and
increasing energy security but now with
these rapidly rising and unpredictable
gas prices the economic case is ever
stronger the tory government has wasted
years of precious time in the
development of renewables including the
moratorium on constructing onshore wind
farms in england and the reduction in
support for solar panels we should have
been far further ahead by now in our
production of electricity through
renewable means and the fact we're not
is an abject failure by this government
to stimulate the production of
renewables
luckily we have the devolved powers in
wales and we were able to continue with
the development of wind power but then
we had the reluctance of the
conservative government to look at the
swansea tidal lagoon but now thanks to
the initiative imagination and hard work
of labour control city and county of
swansea the project will go forward the
government also cut the electrification
plans for the railway line from cardiff
to swansea and has no plans for
electrification further to west wales on
the ground that it would not shorten the
journey time but if we generate
electricity from renewables then
electrification not only helps to tackle
climate change but it also now will
bring price stability
so words are not enough fun deputy
speaker we now need the government to
make a massive effort to increase the
production of electricity from all forms
of renewables on an offshore wind tidal
another marine technologies and solar
and importantly to invest in the
national grid to ensure we can all
benefit from this renewable production
so madame de speaker we want action
felicity perkin who has one minute
thank you madam deputy speaker i'd like
to warmly welcome this bold decisive and
comprehensive measure i think it's
exactly the right thing i welcome in
particular the measures on communal
heating networks which are huge in my
constituency with all of my mansion
blocks and i like the fact that we are
focused on self-reliance i try to
intervene on the leader of the
opposition because he quite rightly
talked about self-reliance when it comes
to energy but the reason partly that
we're not self-reliant is because
because between 1997 and 2010 the labour
party failed to invest in renewables and
energy and our dependence on gas went
from 32
to 46
so all measures here are welcome i
welcome the commitment to net zero and i
welcome the investment and renewables
shadow secretary of state ed miliband
thank you madam deputy speaker before i
address the issues in this debate i want
to send my best wishes to her majesty
the queen
and her family and i know all of our
thoughts and those of the country are
with them at this time
madam deputy speaker there are two
central questions at the heart of this
debate has the government responded to
the emergency that we face in a way that
is fair
and do they recognize the fundamental
truth that the only way to end this
crisis in the long term is to get off
fossil fuels
and i'm afraid the answer on today's
evidence to both questions is no
let me start with the
plan unveiled by the prime minister
earlier labour led the way on the energy
price freeze
we called for it despite doubts
including
from the prime minister i'm glad she's
admitted that she was wrong about that
because we heard throughout this debate
and i want to thank all honourable and
right honourable members who've spoken
in this debate and we've heard
disagreements on each side on this but
we've heard an agreement about the scale
of the emergency facing families
that's why we spent the summer fighting
the energy price freeze
but the devil will be in the detail and
people will want to see the small print
and i do say that the problem is that
bills do still seem to be rising by at
least 129 pounds a year
and the even bigger problem the
fundamental issue in this debate
has been who pays
the right will lady has been clear that
she is against a windfall tax
we know the effects of this madam deputy
speaker it means all of the costs are
loaded onto the british people and let's
dispose of the argument that this is
somehow not about higher taxes
in the end this will have to be paid for
by the british people in higher taxes so
the question is not whether are we we're
going to tax to pay for this but who but
who we are going to tax now let's let's
take the arguments we've heard in this
debate against the windfall tax and
let's take them apart one by one
first the argument that a winful tax
will reduce investment
is there any truth to this as my right
honourable friend leader of the
opposition said in his eloquent speech
the bp boss says it won't have an effect
on uh investment he said when asked
which investments it would affect he
said none of them so even bp don't
believe the argument the prime minister
is mounting in defense of bp
next next we've heard the argument that
a windfall tax can't raise extra money
beyond what the former chancellor
announced let us dispose of this
argument to madam deputy speaker
i gather there is a dispute about this
170 billion in excess profits well i say
the chancellor's not here but i say to
the prime minister we'll publish the
treasury's estimate of the excess
profits if it's not 170 billion we have
it on good authority is 170 billion
publish the estimates so we can all see
them uh for ourselves in any case we
know we i'm think i'm not going to give
way because i've got little time for the
wind up in any case we know there are
tens of billions that could be raised
first of all there are significant
resources from the windfall tax on the
oil and gas companies including the
abolishing the absurd 5 billion pounds
loophole proposed by the chancellor next
there are the electricity generators now
we need to de-link the price of gas and
electricity but that will not happen for
a number of years in the meantime these
companies are making enormous profits
onward a conservative think tank said
this week up to 10 billion a year can be
raised the tony blair institute said 14
billion we could even have a cross-party
consensus on this
why would we leave this money in their
pockets when it could help pay for this
action on energy now i say to the
government the alternative which they
appear to have adopted is to make a
voluntary agreement where the companies
decide to opt in to reduce prices but i
do say that to the house this is a
terrible proposal it came originally
from energy uk because in exchange for
giving up some profits now the deal is
to lock in higher prices over the next
15 years this is not a good deal for
consumers at madame deputy speaker
indeed there is a there is a chart uh
because i'm a nerd i read these charts
uh there is a chart published by energy
uk which precisely sets out the fact
that consumers will pay through the nose
over the 15 years
ahead
the third and final argument we've heard
uh in this debate is that certain indeed
from the prime minister is it somehow
unfair to business here i would take
advantage of the prime minister being
here to recommend her she reads an
article
by mr irwin steltzer who's a long time
confidant of rupert murdoch and in my
experience of tory leaders it's worth
their while to stay on the right side of
him he he wrote this
now is the time for a windfall profit
tax he said people who believe in
capitalism believe that private sector
companies should be rewarded for taking
risks not be rewarded for happening to
be around when some disruption drives up
prices producing windfalls in this case
the barbaric invasion of ukraine so what
is the principle that the prime minister
is defending here what what is what is
the hill on which she stands is the
principle she really wishes to defend
the oil and gas companies should pocket
any scale of profits however bad the
geograph the the political instability
however large the crisis and however
gigantic the windfall taxation must not
change
and the british people instead must take
the strain that is the effect of her
argument and i do say madame deputy
speaker the argument i am making is not
one simply made by lefty suspects like
me
margaret thatcher her heroine she
imposed a windfall tax in 1981. george
osborne who she worked for imposed a
windfall tax in 2011. boris johnson her
very close friend he imposed i think
she's divine george osborne but anyway
uh he imposed i could i can understand
that i can understand that madam david
speaker he imposed in full text two
months ago so she is flying in the face
of logic fairness common sense and
engaging in tens of billions of
borrowing that she does not need to do
and let me make this point let us never
ever again hear lectures from the party
opposite on fiscal responsibility after
the decisions they are making today and
that brings me madam dave speaker to the
longer term let us face facts the only
way out of this crisis is to get off
fossil fuels
i can't do any better than the quote the
words of lord dieben this week and he
and he said this if you want to deal
with climate change and you want to deal
with the cost of living crisis and oil
and gas you have to do the same thing
renewable energy and energy efficiency
and indeed i would add nuclear they are
the answers and that is the central
point
solar and wind energy are nine times
cheaper than gas
you can't solve the fossil fuel crisis
by doubling down on fossil fuels but
that is what the government has done
today with this announcement on fracking
and my wrongful friend quoted the words
of the current uh of the new chancellor
uh in relation to this which is that
fracking would make no difference to
prices and would take years to come on
screen i don't know where the honourable
lady got her six months from that she
said in her statement but the but the
chancellor was saying only a few months
ago it would take 10 years to get
anything out of the ground
on fracking the truth is and this is
where i come to the business secretary
and i want to congratulate him he and i
have known each other a long time we've
had a good personal relationship maybe
we can form an unlikely alliance uh on
the uh on the issues uh uh that we face
but i want to make a serious point madam
deputy speaker to the business secretary
um
about some of what he said in the past
because it does go to these issues
he has said a number of things about
climate
and
i have been part of working on a
cross-party consensus on climate for
getting on for 20 years
uh in this house
and i have to say some of what he has
said
about climate
questioning the modelling
questioning whether there's anything we
can do about the climate crisis saying
in 2017 if we were to take action now to
try and stop man-made global warming it
would have no effect for hundreds or
thousands of years the cost of climate
action is probably unaffordable i quote
those words madam deputy speaker
this is i'm afraid flirtation with
climate denial
never in the last 20 years have we heard
these words from someone in charge of
tackling the climate crisis we should
not normalize this the bipartisan
consensus on climate change has been
hard won
we have worked across parties over two
decades to secure it and there is a
heavy responsibility on the business
secretary to be part of maintaining that
consensus not destroying it
and the problem for him and the reason
why he faces this challenge is this is
not just about the climate crisis
because if we don't take action on green
energy it's a recipe for higher bills
the ban on onshore wind is driving bills
higher gas imports higher and terrible
for the climber the blockages on solar
which the prime minister supports are
driving bills higher gas imports higher
and is terrible for the climber the
refusal to act on energy efficiency is
driving bills higher gas imports higher
and is terrible for the climate and i
say madam deputy speaker there is
nothing more anti-business
than scaring off investors in renewables
with climate denial now here is the
truth and i'm concluding with madame
dave speaker here is the truth about
this new government only two days in i
believe they have revealed their true
colors we face a social and economic
emergency in such an emergency what
matters is who you stand up for who
shoulders the burden and the choices you
make they have chosen to stand up for
the oil and gas gas companies not the
british people who will pay for this in
the long term they cannot answer the
challenges of energy security they
cannot answer the challenges of energy
bills they cannot answer the challenges
of the climate crisis and they have the
wrong priorities for britain
[Music]
secretary of state jacob
[Applause]
um thank you ma'am deputy speaker um may
i begin by adding my voice to those of
honorable and right honourable members
about her majesty the queen and wish her
well
from this house it is a matter of the
gravest concern to all of us when our
sovereign is unwell
um i also want to congratulate my
running friend the prime minister
not only on her appointment but on the
way she has chosen to meet this energy
challenge with immediate and decisive
action
i thank her for introducing this debate
and ensuring that the contents of her
speech were not leaked beforehand which
is a proper respect for parliament
um and to see that her policy has been
robustly debated
in this chamber but i also want to thank
um the chancellor my predecessor
at bays
for paving the way for this announcement
to take take place and i'm looking
forward to working very closely
with him to ensure households and
businesses are protected this winter uh
and beyond and i should also
like to thank the um right honourable
gentleman uh the shadow business
secretary for his kind words about me
and his um opening comments indeed we
have had a friendly personal
relationship um over some years so i
hope we can continue that whilst having
no doubt a less friendly debate
sometimes on these fundamental issues
but man deputy speaker we need to
understand why we are here we are on
here because vladimir putin has
weaponized energy supply as part of his
barbarous attack in ukraine
last week he turned off the main
pipeline to europe and it is a
deliberate blackmail tactic against the
west britain's energy system must be
strengthened and diversified to protect
our homes and our businesses and as
we've heard over the course of this
debate our plan comes in two parts
first we must get our constituents
safely through this winter we know how
concerned people are about expensive
energy bills and some of the projected
figures have been truly alarming and we
are intervening to stave off an
unprecedented crisis
it would be wrong to stand by
as people struggle
and i can give the assurance to the
honourable lady the late members and
albans that our plan for businesses will
include care homes that is fundamentally
important
and it would be madness to ignore other
businesses too as they see their bills
spiral out of control
so
the new energy price guarantee will
ensure bills are kept down remaining at
around 2500 pounds a year for the
average consumer this intervention
reflects the severity of the situation
we find ourselves in and the government
funded support will take effect from the
1st of october saving the average
household around a thousand pounds this
will be combined with the initial
original support that we have announced
and so i can reassure the honourable
member for kilmarnock and loudon who
raised the question first that we will
be acting to help the people on the
lowest incomes the government has
already announced a package of support
that will see 8 million of the most
vulnerable households receive 1 200
pounds of one-off support to help with
the cost of living and all domestic
electricity consumers will receive 400
pounds
and we know
that from biscuit makers to bars
businesses are worried about their bills
and the government price guarantee for
businesses will be announced shortly
will bring down energy bills for the
acute phase of this crisis
all businesses on variable contracts
whose fixed price contract is coming to
an end all those businesses who have
agreed a fixed price contract recently
will be eligible to enter the new
government guaranteed contract
this will apply to businesses of all
sizes and include schools nurseries and
care homes as well as manufacturers and
retail
that is the short term
and quite rightly members of the
opposition particularly the leader of
the opposition asked who is going to pay
for this
well the energy bills guarantee is not a
direct lane to customers or to energy
suppliers however as the price
stabilizes in due course the government
will need to consider when and how to
recoup at least some of the cost of the
scheme
and the opposition are all for taxation
madam deputy speaker this shouldn't
surprise you actually as you know the
inner workings of the labour party
probably better than most but
nonetheless all we get
from the other side is tax tax and tax
again it may be that we are at the
highest rate of taxation in 70 years but
the answer is always more tax
it is their only answer to any question
even the honorable gentleman the leader
of the snp who used to be a very
successful businessman and therefore
made nothing or two about this was
advocating higher taxes but now he's a
humble crofter perhaps he thinks that's
easy
i am i'm grateful for the right of
remember we go back a long way and if of
course it's trying to have a background
in the city but
he no doubt has read shells quarterly
figures as i have done if i from the top
of my head the return on capital
employed has gone up from three to
thirteen percent by anyone's definition
mr spartan deputy speaker that's excess
profits and it's right at a time such as
this that we take our share of that yeah
it is structurally wrong madame deputy
speaker taxes need to be certain if you
are to encourage investment and we need
investment in this country the tax
policy has to be set for the long term
you cannot retrospectively pick people's
pocket you need to tell them what the
charge will be beforehand and keep it
clear i'll give way certainly
would the business secretary like to
remind the house that the republic of
ireland shows deliberately much lower
corporation tax rates than the rest of
the advanced world and collects a far
bigger proportion of its economy in
taxes on business than we do yeah good
point my right honourable friend will be
glad to note that the chance of
exchequer from the sedentary position is
agreeing with him and my rightful friend
is a higher authority on this than i am
but we know that the cutting corporation
tax led to an increase
in receipts
higher taxation is not the answer
so
looking at the long term we must fix our
broken energy system we must have energy
independence and become a net exporter
of energy by 2040 we cannot be held
captive by volatile global markets or
malevolent states we must tackle the
root causes of problems in our energy
market by boosting domestic supply
now this is investing in renewable
energy with vim and vigor accelerating
the deployment of wind solar and
particularly exciting i think hydrogen
technologies so to reassure my
honourable friend the member for pendle
we will invest in nuclear technologies
which also provide us with cheap and
clean electricity and i know my old
friend the member of englishmon uh was
saying it is known as energy island and
that's exactly what we need in this
country uh my old friend the member for
gloucester notes we are
not just in this man but the whole of
the united kingdom is energy island and
so we must use all the resources
available to us including as my royal
friend the member from maidenhead said
tidal energy this is a great opportunity
i i would love to give way but time is
very short and we are fully committed to
green growth and the green industrial
revolution and to net zero by 2050
but
we've got to get there and to get there
we are going to need
oil and gas
so we are going to have a new oil and
gas licensing round looking hoping to
launch it in october
and i want to reassure the honorable
gentleman for east antrim um that we
will
work with communities and individuals to
use shale gas as well with the support
of those who may be affected so the
pores on extraction is being lifted
through a written ministerial statement
which will come into effect immediately
this will allow us to gather further
data on seismic safety but it is
fundamentally important as any economist
know pricing is set at the margin if you
have more it helps bring prices down
that is fundamental and it is not in any
way contradictory to what we have been
saying before
um we will also have um
legislation to support people in
northern ireland which i think is
fundamentally important we must be one
united kingdom
in how in how we do this i am very
grateful for the many contributions made
during the course of this debate from my
honorable friend the member for
worcester the my rival friend from
central devon right old friend for
forrest of dean and for south north
hamptonshire my own friend the member
for bolton west and my right home friend
the member for priscilla pembrokeshire
my honourable friend the memphis surrey
and for watford my own friend the
memphis gloucester i've always mentioned
my right old friend the member for
basingstoke for innismon um for dudley
south and um for
seven oaks but man deputy speaker i beg
to move this motion on the order paper
uh before i put the question just to say
i'm very sorry that um
all honourable and writers members were
not able to get into the debate it was
uh very oversubscribed
and also a reminder that it is important
to get back in good time for the
wind-ups
in order to hear responses to what
people have said
the question is that this house has
considered
uk energy costs as many as our of that
opinion say i
the country no
i think the eyes have it the eyes have
it
and before we uh move on to the
the next business i do also wish to pass
on uh my thoughts and best wishes and i
know those of the people too of
doncaster central to her majesty the
queen and her yeah
we now come to the motion relating to
the
social security uh special news from the
live bill lords allocation of time
minister to move
the question is as on the order paper as
many as i have that opinion say i
the country no i think the eyes have it
the eyes have it clark will now proceed
to read the orders of the day
social security special rules end of
life bill lord's second reading
you say now
minister secretary of state chloe smith
to move second reading
thank you very much indeed madam deputy
speaker and i beg to move that this bill
be now read a second time may i also say
it's a pleasure to do so in this role
and may i welcome the new member of my
ministerial team the honourable member
for banbury who will be taking later
stages of today's
bill madame deputy speaker finding out
that your illness cannot be cured can be
a frightening experience and as a
government we are committing to doing
all that we can to alleviate the
pressures facing those who are nearing
the end of their lives
and their families
to provide some financial security to
those who find themselves in this
difficult position the department for
work and pensions has since the 1990s
provided access to key benefits via what
is often referred to as the special
rules
these are benefit rules which enable
people who are nearing the end of their
lives to get fast track access to
certain benefits
historically those eligible under these
rules have not had to wait as long to
start getting benefit payments they've
not been required to go through medical
assessments and in most cases have
qualified for higher rates of benefit in
order to access this fast tracked route
people had to be assessed by their
healthcare professional as having six
months or less to live and this became
known as the six-month rule for more
than 30 years then these special rules
have ensured that at this most difficult
time people have got the financial
support that they are entitled to
quickly and easily but of course it's
the case that since those rules were
first introduced there have been
significant advances in how the nhs
treats and cares for people nearing the
end of their lives meaning that many
terminally ill people are now living
longer
given these advances in july 2019 the
department launched an in-depth
evaluation of how the benefit system
supports people nearing the end of their
lives and as part of that consultation
the department worked with
those people and those that support them
and clinicians and the evaluations
findings show that there was consensus
across all groups that the government
should extend the current six-month rule
it showed support for the dwp to adopt a
12-month end-of-life